how is everybody
sorry we were a little bit late was it
15 minutes late
it's just that um the muggler has come
close enough much longer
how is everyone good um
okay i don't know who we've got here any
atheist christians at the moment who
knows okay
so any of you who's new to the arena let
me explain what the arena is
so basically it's a format where you can
come on
and you can question and challenge um
the gladiators in the arena with regards
islam or if you want to try and prove
christianity or or if you're an atheist
or whatever um
come and challenge us yeah that's what
we're here for um marshall i've got some
really
good uh solid gladiators today
insha'allah so
without further ado i'm gonna bring the
first collateral gladiator
by insha'allah yusuf whenever he looks
at his what's up
and uh nope still looks what's up okay
and brother
uh sorry brother uh sabor inshallah um
so without further ado i'm gonna put the
link out there and let's get them all
i don't know if we've got anyone in it
waiting to come on yet i was
schooling some christians today so
hopefully they come back with some
responses but
that's a great looking sweater brother
hamza it really suits you
well this one oh thank you very much
yeah yeah it looks cool well thank
you very much thank you yeah feel good
you're a good guy to have around man you
may feel like you know you're 10 foot
tall man
it was like i
right let me just um pin that link
yeah so i had a did you see my i was
speaking to arsenal earlier last friday
i did a stream
and what i did was i um i invited chris
because i've always said this thing that
sorry christians always say that we
bully christians we bring one question
on and five of us pounce on them yeah
and so i say look if your argument's
strong enough it doesn't matter how many
people are dealing with you
yeah so what i said was look
last week i brought three different
questions on and rob is here now he rubs
in the chat
rob's first guest right and i brought
rob on two other christians
and amongst themselves they were
complete disagreement on the
fundamentals of salvation
just the fundamentals forget the
incarnation forget anything else
just the fundamentals so this was like
an evidence the fact that
we can't have more than one christian at
a time because they'll spend most of
their time disagreeing
anyway i'll bring rob on while i pin the
link
what's going on yeah can you hear me
can you hear me sorry what'd you say
mate
yeah can you me can you hear me can we
hear what
okay all right all right now listen be
careful how you respond to me
salaam alaikum
okay the reason i gave the warning
was because i've come across some very
disturbing hadith
rob just make your point
okay so the particular hadith that i'm
referring to
is in uh jamaat madi
uh it's 27.00 so
2700 and
um i'll i'll actually read you the
hadith
because you're aware rob rob
go ahead go ahead make your point i want
see what it is i want
to make a point yeah so we can deal with
the point what's the point you're making
are you saying islam teaches what or
whatever
and this is your evidence no problem
what's your claim
okay so i would be joking
if i said that this is a very beautiful
hadith
because re the truth is it's right we're
gonna we're gonna start again rob all
right we're gonna start from the
beginning
i'm gonna come on and you're gonna make
your point
all right it's teddy darren
hamza rob right listen you're not on the
stream right now no one can hear you
i want you to come on and make your
point and then you can bring all your
reasons and evidence and your feelings
and how it affects you when all that
business
later make your point so you're saying
islam teaches this as a muslim you
should be like this
and then we'll be deal with it okay
so very politely like using quran 2946
this hadith is full of discrimination
so what's your point yeah i mean
you know you you're saying that oh you
know
what's your point i get i give you one
last chance for up what's your point
the point is that this is horrible
discrimination against
christians what's horrible
discrimination against christians
well this this hadith one amongst others
guys
okay so uh yeah i'm looking at it right
now thank you rob yeah thanks for the
question
yeah so rob i'm going to address it if i
can
okay yeah so yeah in the hadith uh the
prophet peace be upon him
he says
which means do not be the first do not
precede them do not initiate the
greeting of
salaam so the the that kind of that bait
or that trap
that you set out for us doesn't really
make sense because you preceded us in
saying salaam you greeted us with peace
and we we should respond to you in the
same way so you you respond you greeted
us with peace we responded to you in
peace
although in spirit i think you weren't
coming in peace because you were
actually trying to
uh trap us and and make us look bad so
isn't that being hypocritical greeting
us with peace when you don't really mean
peace but
i actually mean it uh you know peace be
upon you as well
but the prophet did say in that hadith
you're right about not uh preceding the
jews in the salaam
uh and to and to uh force them to the
side of the road however
like every hadith out there like every
report out there
like every uh historical report out
there
like every quranic verse out there like
every biblical
verse out there everything has a context
and the context of this hadith was
if i remember correctly was that the
muslims were marching
towards the fortress uh uh
hold out of the banu koresa tribe so
they were basically on
a military march on a military campaign
against
a group of jews not all the jews of the
world against a particular tribe of the
jews
and so in that context if you were to
come across them of course then
you're not going to initiate the salam
because islam doesn't teach us to be
hypocrites
so when we say when we initiate the the
salam it means i actually wish peace be
up
on you if i'm going to go to battle
against you
if your tribe and my group are at war
with each other
it doesn't make much sense that i should
initiate and say peace be upon you
when i'm going to be fighting you the
next minute but okay can i respond can i
respond can i respond
i'm i'm done if you wish peace be upon
me then it is allowed for us to say
alaikum or even wa alaykum peace be upon
you as well
if you truly come in peace right i love
i love you guys i love you guys
i want you in heaven with me i love you
guys
salaam alaikum i i love you guys
yeah welcome but your prophet hated me
didn't he
he hated me why did you believe
so right rob if you're going to if
you're going to use that hadith
unless you've got more ammunition on you
if you're going to use that
yes let me let me just wrap this up if
you're trying to use that hadith if that
was your starter right
to try to prove that we hate you um
do do i mean look i don't even like
really playing these kind of games
because
some muslims will take these points
seriously and and i want to actually try
to be fair to the other side so
i'm making the difference is it okay
is it a religion rob so bro
i'm i'm making the disclaimer that uh
that
this is not actually how i take the
bible but i'm showing you that
the bible could be taken in this way
when for example
uh jesus says to let the dead bury their
own dead
in other words the unbelievers even if
they're from your own family
imagine your mother's a non-christian
that's sorry i'm sorry
sorry that's nothing that is not
relevant
whatsoever of course it is because
you're coming in here as a christian you
identified yourself well
to be fair you didn't but i'm 99.9 sure
you can correct me if i'm wrong
that you are a christian because we
don't get that many buddhists coming on
wishing telling us they love us and they
want us to go to heaven it's a very
kind of christian cliche thing to do so
i'm assuming that you're christian and
if you are
of course it's relevant because jesus
peace be upon him says
that why do you take the splinter out of
your brother's eye when there's a log in
your own
eye so if you're going to complain about
us discriminating against
non-muslims by the way discrimination is
not always an evil
word right when i come to the uk they
discriminate there's a one line for the
british passport holders and the eu
passport holders and then there's
another line for those who are not
british eu
that's discrimination but it's not a
negative evil kind of discrimination i
don't have any particular problem with
it
i'm saying to you that if you're going
to complain against islam
discriminating then what about your own
religion what about your own book
how come jesus said can i respond should
i repent
one minute you shouldn't be yoked you
shouldn't be yoked believers
i know whatever you want to hear this
stuff yeah no no no sadaq can i respond
you've had a long yeah what are you
responding to
the point they just made the point the
which one though he made a few points he
made the point that
according to the bible you do um
discriminate are you responding to that
right i know you i know your waffle rob
so i need to make sure you respond to
the correct thing
my response to what sadat just said and
accused
is how many mosques sadda
have been built in this country and been
allowed to proceed
how many churches in saudi arabia what
are you talking about
let me let me explain are you seriously
sorry i was just accusing you
of bro something for the table let me
come in let me explode
even even even though i know he's
throwing out red hearings but sometimes
red herrings are tempting and i end up
chasing them
seriously rob are you seriously
suggesting that
um what that that historically or even
today i haven't
done an actual account britain has more
mosques than
let's say syria has churches
and what's your evidence how many
churches
are to be allowed
in saudi arabia but why pick one country
out of out of 40 plus or 50 plus
majority muslim countries i could say to
you
how many mosques are there in greece or
how many mosques are there in athens
how many mosques are there in how many
oscar there in east germa
uh in east berlin in germa so we we
could pick
an isolated once we said that said that
we've given islam the red carpet in this
country
they haven't done the same for us rob
yeah that's why you have prevent right
and that's why you hunt down children
and try to throw their parents in jail
for radicalizing them because
we don't like terrorism of course we
don't of course we don't like terrorism
of course we don't like
we give roses to the terrorists we give
roses to the terrorists
what you're talking about most
non-muslims are treated better in
malaysia
than muslims are treated in the uk i
don't know
i don't know if you've been following
the news here in canada but they're they
are literally
digging up mass graves of indigenous
children right now in canada
and yesterday the canada day
celebrations were that's changing the
topic
that's changing the topic
changing the topic missionary
residential schools
yeah about that's changing
that is disgusting
what happened out there is disgusting
and that's changing
rob let me ask you a question yeah um
how many mosques are there in the
vatican
there's loads of mosque in italy in the
there are lots and lots of mosques in
italy vatican
vatican is not illiterate vatican is not
italy
well the vatican is not that big the
vatican how many
are there how many mosques are there
they're not going to build a mosque
right next to the vatican are they why
not
why not that's discrimination not
discrimination
anyway what i want to talk about is
discrimination i want to i don't want
exposure hypocrisy
what was the church father's viewings of
jews
there might have been some um
uh you know there might have been some
underlying tension
underlying tension okay and what was
calvin's views of jews
there's some more innovation between
what we need
what was called because we're going to
talk about discrimination here
i'm going to do that i'm going to do i'm
going to read some minutes
uh
yeah there was some underlying tension
there sorry let me read this underlying
tension right
uh it's gonna be a bit long because me
and uh me and yousef were just
talking about this right have you seen
what luther said about jews
i i need your channel to get in trouble
hamza i don't know if you can read it i
don't know if you can
see why i can't read it because this is
what this is quoting christian
remote reformist all right yeah have you
have you heard us
what he said but everybody
take note because we get this idea we
get this projection
that apparently somehow islam
discriminates against jews wants to kill
jews and all of these things now we all
know the history of andalusia
we all know for 800 years the jews were
protected and secured by the muslims
from christian slaughter the islamic
jewish golden age occurred in andalusia
subhanallah now what was behind this
um sentiment why did the jews need to
be protected from christian slaughter
and we're talking christian slaughter um
i have to go there because i was just
reading it and it was just like mental
so um i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it you don't mind if i do
it here
go ahead i think the people need to hear
this no i think christians need to pin
back their ears
who are falling over israel today they
need to pin back their ears
because this is your church fathers um
okay
let's let's start with john
chrysostom john chrysostom
was from 340 a.d one of the greatest of
church fathers known as the golden
mouthed missionary preacher
famous for his sermons and addresses so
this giza's got credence
the synagogue is worse than a brothel
it is the dennis scoundrels and the
repair of wild beasts
the temple of demons devoted to
idolatrous cults the refuge of brigands
and departures
and the cavern of devils it is a
criminal assembly of jews a place of
meeting for the assassins of christ
a house worse than a drinking shop a den
of fees a house of ill fame a dwelling
of iniquity
the refuge of devils a gulf and an abyss
of petition
i would say the same thing about their
souls as for me
i hate the synagogue i hate the jews for
the same reason
so this is church father right
um
who was it who was it said burn the
synagogues down
and was that uh anyway i want to um
get to martin luther because this is in
1543.
now this could be from minecamp what i'm
about to read
what then shall we call what then shall
we christians do with this damned
rejected race of jews since they live
among us and we know about their lying
and blasphemy and cursing
we cannot tolerate them if we do not
wish to share in their lives
curses and blasphemy in this way we
cannot quench the inextinguishable
fire of divine rage nor convert the jews
we must pray fully and reversally
practice a merciful severity perhaps we
may save a few from the fire and flames
of hell
we must not seek vengeance they are
surely being punished a thousand times
more than we might wish them
let me give you my honest advice first
their synagogue should be set on fire
and whatever does not burn up should be
covered or spread over with dirt
so no one may ever be able to see a
cinder or stone of it
and this ought to be done for the honor
of god and of christianity
in order that god may see that we are
christians and that we have not
wittingly tolerated or approved of such
public lying
cursing and blaspheming of his son and
his christians
secondly their homes should likewise be
broken down and destroyed
for they perpetrate the same things
there that they do in their synagogues
for this reason they ought to be put
under one roof or in a stable
like gypsies in order that they may
realize that they are not masters in our
land
as they boast but miserable captives as
they complain of incessantly before god
with bitter wailing
thirdly they should be deprived of their
prayer books and talmuds
with such idolatry lies cursing and
blasphemy are taught
fourthly their rabbis must be forbidden
of the threat of death
to teach anymore fifthly passport and
traveling privileges should be
absolutely forbidden to the jews
for they have no business in the rural
district since they are not nobles nor
officials nor merchants
nor the like let them stay at home if
you princes and nobles do not close the
road legally to such exploiters
then some troop ought to ride against
them for they will learn from this
pamphlet that what the jews are and how
to handle them
and that they ought not to be protected
you ought not you cannot protect them
unless in the eyes of god you want to
share all their abomination
to sum up dear princes and nobles who
have jews in your domains
i think that music didn't complement the
quote very well you know
honestly honestly right um
it's to sum up dear princess nobody if
you're jesus do not if this advice of
mine does not suit you then find a
better one so that we may
all free of this insufferable devilish
burden the jews
let the government deal with them in
their respect as i have suggested but
whether the government acts or not let
everyone at least be guided by his own
conscience
and form for himself a definition or
image of a jew
when you lay eyes on one think of a jew
you must say to yourself
at last that mouth which i there which i
behold has cursed and excreted
excreted and maligned every saturday my
dear lord jesus christ
who has redeemed me with his precious
blood in addition it prayed and listened
to this
this is madness this part in addition it
has it prayed and pleaded before god
that i
and my wife and children all christians
might be stabbed to death
and perish miserably and he himself
would gladly do this
if he were able in order to appropriate
our goods
such a desperate thoroughly evil
poisonous and devilish lot are these
jews
who for these 1400 years have been and
still our plague our pestilence and our
misfortune
i have read and heard many stories about
the jews which agree with this judgment
of christ
namely how they have poisoned wells made
assassinations
kidnapped children as related before
i've heard that they
one jew sent another jew and by this
means of a christian a pot of blood
together with a barrel of wine in which
when a drunk empty a dead jew was found
there are many other similar stories for
their kidnapping of children
they have been burned at the stake or
banished i am well aware that they all
deny of this
however all coincides with the judgment
of christ which declares that they are
venomous bitter vindictive tricky
serpents assassins
and children of the devil who sing who
sting and work harm
stealthily whatever they cannot do it
openly for this reason
i would like to see them there are no
christians i would like to see them
where there are no christians
the turks and other heathen do not
tolerate what we christians endure from
these venomous serpents
and young devils next to the devil a
christian has no bitter and galling
full than a jew there is no other to
whom we accord as many benefactions and
from whom we suffer as much as we do
from these base children of the devil
this brood of vipers
flipping neck i mean at this point hamas
would be saying take it easy man
we got some political beef with the
israelis but yeah let's take it easy
so that was martin luther yeah
i mean rob was right there there's
there's some underlying tension there
between my attention and john calvin so
all your calvinists out there
there the jews rotten and unbending
stiff-neckedness deserves that they be
oppressed
unendingly and without measure or end
and that they die in their misery
without the pity of anyone
we're talking about discrimination
respond to the potential
responses by the christians in the chat
elsewhere that
while this may have been statements by
the church fathers doesn't represent
christianity
and although that may be true the point
that we're trying to make i think is
that it does represent
christian policy that occurred
throughout history in fact that's the
reason why jews
typically ran to muslim lands in order
to escape persecution by
christian governments because they knew
that the muslims had a very strict law
when it came to
political plurality so what i mean by
that is that in islamic law
as all of us are all should be aware of
muslims jews christians and other
religious groups could live peaceably by
themselves without any sort of
intervention
as long as they paid a small tax right
and then everyone they just and they
preferred that
whereas in christian lands for the most
part it didn't matter if they how much
they paid or whatever they would be
persecuted to no end and slaughtered
or you know destroyed uh in some way or
another
so you know that's why for example we
brought up earlier that antarctica for
example
uh muslims had their golden age because
they were allowed to
you know it's funny because a lot of
christians today they're very
anachronistic they think that the
policies towards um
jews in israel today showcased in europe
in the united states is indicative of
what
historically has occurred and that's not
the case the love affair between the
the western world and israel is a recent
one primarily political
and and uh pushed by evangelical
christians
you know um but it is not the historical
uh account of of how christians have
typically
in in their government in their
political policies treated jews
and now it's funny because now they're
projecting anti-semitism onto the muslim
world
when it's like as though as though the
last 200 years or even less than that
have been
the full extent of history and it's like
no it hasn't
we need to wake up and read a book over
the last 200 years or even less than
that
could have been full extent well i think
you're causing an echo bro
in fact um one one thought that has
crossed my mind and slumly come there
too brother saboor
long time ago
even though i think uh i'm going off on
a little bit of a tangent here but i
think this whole
cancel culture in the political realm is
going a little bit overkill
here in canada i know similar things are
happening in the us and the uk
and every statue of every political
leader is being
you know brought down or or vandalized
or graffitied
and uh but i wonder how is it that the
lutheran church has been
left off the hook uh let off the hook
how is it that the
calvinist church has been led off the
hook now i'm not even suggesting that
they should be forced to
change their name just to prove that
they're not racist i think this thing's
overkill and
it might even have a racist backlash
eventually but i'm just
i'm just observing that i'm surprised
that no
jewish group has called upon
the lutheran church to say hey just
change your name keep keep your
theology your rituals everything the
same just change the name because even
you guys admit you don't
uh agree with many of the things that
luther said and same thing goes for the
calvinist church
i'm so happy rob came on with such a
pathetic point oh and
i want to be clear too i didn't get much
time to talk about it but like you know
the whole idea oh yeah you know
we rolled out the red carpet in the uk
for the muslims it's like
are you joking like where have you been
like you know you're sitting in the pub
watching football every single day like
have you not walked outside for once
and i mean the police like prevent
policy by itself is indicative
of how much of a red carpet there is for
muslims in the uk
look the example of that bro is when you
see the hindus building their temples
the world got elephant gods and this
about all that
the sikhs have their big temples the
muslims have to like hide in the houses
they have to turn houses in tomorrow
you cut you can't get the purpose built
things you get me is the idea that
um there's a red carpet out for us
muslims and like you said to prevent
strategy and such
it's it's also what he implied and
didn't say uh so
because often what's being implied there
is that while we christians roll out the
red
carpet for you muslims right so i i
correct them on this and i say look
the same government that gives lgbtq
rights
the same government that gives gays
rights to get married the same
government
uh that that that supports
transgenderism that same liberal
uh style of government has given us
muslims the right to build mosques and
and and to teach islam here so it's not
like we owe
the church you know whether that's the
anglican church
or the catholic church it's not like we
owe a thanks to them
for for letting us in right
the same government that that that that
legalizes
uh drug use that legalizes weed here in
canada the
the same government that turns a blind
eye to prostitution the same government
in the us that allows
pornography is that a christian
government doing all of those things
not not quite not really it's it's far
more complicated than that right all
right
let's bring on the next guest now this
next guest was upset with me today
because um
i did a live a warm up the arena yeah
because i've been baiting christians on
tick tock all
for the past two weeks just challenging
them on christianity to come explain to
the world why they believe christianity
is true and this christian came on but
there was another christian he's been
trying to get onto my tick tock for a
while couldn't get on so i got them onto
my stream today and
we had a i had a field day anyway so
this becca newman who's coming on now i
don't know what
their position is but they were very
upset thought i was running from them
and this that the other
so just to give you a little background
so
beckham newman welcome to the arena
could you put like a bit of a meat to
your voice can i hear you
um so can you hear me
now i can hear you okay so i would like
uh shall i start my
topic or would you like to ask something
okay so the way it works here in the
arena you make a claim make your point
make a contention
i'll make sure i'll highlight that that
is what point you're trying to make
yeah and then the boys will respond to
you
so my claim here is uh that al quran is
enough
okay okay
so i would like to divide on uh to
debate on this topic so
a few people would like to uh right so
just so i understand
i'm assuming you're a headache projector
is that correct uh
i can't i don't want to say that uh i
reject
this i would like to call this do you
rejected heath
um well it depends uh if
you accept the nato rejected well
i just delight uh this uh delaying the
understand that uh
i wanna investigate a hadith for later
that
do you accept hadith or reject hadith i
think it's
right now i don't i don't have to accept
or reject
it's like do you believe it's important
to know what the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him taught
uh of course it's important it is
important
yeah do you believe i'm just i'm not
answering you i'm just trying to
establish a position
do you believe you understand the quran
better than muhammad peace's
blessings be upon him i knew that you
that's this
let me i was prepared for this so
and uh i don't understand better than
the prophet of course you don't
okay but uh i was prepared to the
discretion here should i go on with my
list or
should i share your question uh well
you've not stopped
you've not told us your position you you
you seem to be rejecting honey
you you seem to believe you only need
the quran and nothing
no explanations of it so so you're
basically saying you don't need the
prophet peace the blessing upon him
to help you understand the quran because
you understand the quran just as well as
he could
that's basically what i never said that
i never said no you don't have to say
that's what you say
it's the strongman policy uh let me
continue i wanted to say
shall i question the prophet like jesus
questions
so um
what i mean is so in in that case
brother
do you believe that the authority of the
hadiths were abrogated
at some early point in time in other
words do you believe that there was
a time in early islam or during the time
of the prophet peace be upon him
when the use of hadiths and the
authority of hadith
was permitted it was allowed i hope you
understood my question
okay okay yeah i understood the question
now the question but
um let me think that hadees
was that even um
was that he was supposed to be followed
like when was a hadith first
written down about that in the time of
the prophet peace be upon him
or uh in the time of maria
or doctor beckham i i have to stop you
just a second i just have to have a
house okay
this is like all right okay
right now
are you saying that hadith paris are the
hadith
are they historically reliable or not
reliability well i would like to
see the truth for the no i didn't say
that i didn't
no no no okay so i'm asking you a
question
do you believe they're historically
reliable or not
i need proofs why why
do you believe they're historically
reliable or not
i totally i have delighted that for late
investigations
like in surah
are we going to continue with this
because i can't do this okay
he's accusing me of just his position
when he's not even telling us his
position
uh my position i'm
i mean just for the benefit of the
listeners where i was curious and going
with that
and if if another quran only don't use
that to
tee off no problem yeah no and if if
another quran only comes on in the
future maybe this is something that they
can think about
is that were hadiths ever allowed did
they ever
have authority for us in the religion or
they or did they never
if if they say they they never did it
was only meant to be the quran
then the follow-up question could be
that if we all lived during the time of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
if he issued us a command which was not
in the quran per se
would we be obligated to listen to him
to follow him
if he given if he gave an explanation
about
uh how to do a particular prayer like
dua kunut
the style of how to do it would we
follow his advice on that or would we
say
leave us alone you did your job you
recited the quran
now if his answer is of course of course
we revere the prophet we believe in the
prophet as well
we would take his advice and his
guidance and we would follow what he
says
because whatever he tells us would not
would not ever contradict the quran
it would only complement it well then
when
when did when did the uh efficacy of his
words
stop what does that mean that you would
have followed oral hadiths at that time
but then they became abrogated their
authority became abrogated later on it
wasn't preserved
and if it wasn't preserved what are the
implications of that was the deen
properly preserved then
did the did the uh early generations
have access to more islamic knowledge
than we would have i mean you see all
the problems related with that
this is this is this is the point i'm
trying to establish because
when you speak to a hadith rejecter they
hide behind the smoke screen of 200
years
they say oh the baha'i came 20 years the
reality is this
do they believe that if it could be
authenticated they could be
determined demonstrated that the prophet
did indeed say this thing
would you act upon it and their answer
is no
right their answer is no they believe
that the prophet saws was only to
deliver the quran
and they i mean i've had quranis and
hadith rejecters tell me
that they understand the quran just as
well as muhammad sasson
and this is the reality now that guy
didn't you know
he didn't mumble that point but he
implied
that point because you can't say you
don't
need to know what processon said that
means you can understand the quran
better than the prophet muhammad said it
right right
so so you've got so if he's got a
problem with
following the prophet muhammad saws on
him then that's another story if his
problem is with the hadith
and can we know for sure that the what
we're reading today was actually said by
the prophet saws
that's a different that's a different uh
path to go on
um and to accuse the strong man in his
position manfred
there we try that best man i i i did
what was i was doing my
my class today with yousef right and i
was asking him right
what's a steel man when you steal man
someone's position right
because for me i believe that steel man
has to be the opposite of a straw man
so you're trying to help that person put
their argument together for them
you're trying to show them so this is
this is what you're saying so this is
what you're trying to say
you couldn't even do that yeah the other
thing is as someone who went through a
quran only phase myself
in my teens you know look the the reason
i think the psychological emotional
reason behind this quran only trend
right
is ultimately we want we want the deen
to be much much much much easier and
much more liberal
and much more um politically agreeable
and so forth right
so now in a tug of war there's two ways
you can make the opponent fall you can
either
overpower him and make him fall or or
what else you can just
let go right you can just let go of the
rope and watch how far he falls
so i'm a fan of this second approach and
what i do is i kind of
test these quran only people to see just
how liberal
and how free are they willing to become
for example for example
and i apologize to to the to the viewers
and especially the sisters right but
you know i say okay look you know can
can can a muslim man have
10 wives or 20 wives and and can he have
relations with them intimate relations
with them
all at once you know having group sex
you'll say no of course not man that's
disgusting that's give me the verse from
the quran that says you can't do that
right and they'll say well the quran
says marry two or three or four yeah but
it doesn't say you can only marry four
and no more than that
right um so uh so could they have ten
wives fifteen wives okay let's say even
only four wives can you have intimate
relations with them all at once
right they'll say no no of course not
man that goes against hayah modest yeah
but where's your
dalil from the quran what's your quranic
verse for that right
or or if if if um
if if if hamza if you caught somebody
stealing from your shop
right well can you grab them and cut off
their hand just just apply the hud right
there right
now even the quran only guy is going to
say no of course not it has to go to a
court
it has to be in a muslim country yeah
but what's your proof from the quran the
quran didn't say all that
the quran didn't say all that the quran
said cut his hand off
so in theory then muslims in england
should do that if somebody steals from
the shop just grab the thief cut off his
hand
so if we give these kinds of examples to
quran only people i think
some of them will realize just how uh
perverse and ludicrous than the
implications would be
of their quran only methodology
i mean this is his response did you kick
me out if you told me i could leave
won't you crush me as you claimed
my friend you you have indeed been
crushed
and the problem is you don't recognize
it you know the other thing too i think
it's not just uh this wanting to be a
liberal sentiment i think it also has a
lot to do with the fact that
most these people who when the first
time they read hadith they're reading
basically they go on like a website or
something like an anti-islam website and
they see this hadith's post and like oh
my god you know how i can't explain it
because they don't bother to go look up
other hadith they don't understand how
other hadith are interpreted
in context of the hadith and stuff and
then they just give up
you know they just give up right there
and they go okay now i have to get rid
of all this in order to keep my religion
because my values don't agree with this
principle so it's like they've already
been somewhat
um it's not so much liberalism i think
there is
that plays a part but i think it's also
their inability to come to
comprehend the hadith corpus to
understand what hadith are and within
those context
and um you know there are so many hadith
especially like on warfare
and everything and they're so easy to
explain when you look at other hadith in
the context of those events that
occurred
you know and those punishments and
everything else that happened but they
don't want to go that far we live in a
very intellectually lazy period in our
history
let me be frank you know and i'm just
talking about muslims i'm talking about
people in general
you know everyone wants like an argument
the size of a meme and if it's not if
it's larger than a meme then it's too
much for them their their brains explode
you know it's like oh my god you know
it's it's two sentences long it's not
for the law
you know no one no one has the patience
to read moby dick
all right i'm trying to work out what
this next person is that's a joke from
one of brother assad
live streams he read moby dick i think
two times or three times and that's all
right man
that is a superhuman feat yeah
i've only seen the movie i've never seen
i've never read the book just sorry one
more thing
it's it's uh if you really want to have
fun with the quran only you know
just you know just show them the huffs
and the water and show certain
differences in the kerahat you know
so like uh quran uh chapter three verse
in the huffs it says uh which means
they desire and then in the water it
says
which means you desire so now you ask
the quran only hey which
one is the quran here which one is the
quran
now they can't fall back on any standard
normative sunni explanation and say well
there's hadith there's different
wait a minute the quran didn't say that
it was revealed in different
so so before you tell me to follow the
quran only
define what the quran is in the first
place which one is it
yeah the problem i'd have with that
argument is that her tune might be
listening
yeah yeah but you should be going i
shall be going around
what is it is it they are or you are
no and you're exactly right you're
exactly right you take that j smith
hathune argument
and show the quran only that they have
no way of responding to that
right the muslim does the sunni muslim
does the shia muslim does but
they have no way of responding to hathon
or j smith without the sunnah
without the hadith without scholarship
without sahabah
you have no way of answering that
question subhanallah because she
all i've ever heard going on but it's
holds in the narrative and christians
saying holes in the narrative
and honestly i feel like going to
speaker's corner right just to
go to hartoon and say what are the holes
yeah and and with the with the quran
only what is the narrative
how did the quran reach us what is the
quran how do you define
how did it get to us how did the quran
get to us they don't even have a
narrative like the
quran only don't have a narrative of how
the quran reached us
without without all of these uh
narrations and things like the screening
it's like what is the quran like what
what is it talking about who is it
talking about who is it from
like they say although they were like
where does it say that
you know it doesn't say these things if
we just had the quran by itself
and a lot of civilization came upon it
would they really know would they
interpret it in the same way that we
interpret it now
they could say it's talking about elijah
muhammad right for example they could
say something oh this is oh this
maybe this guy named muhammad like 10
years ago or something or or ahmed or
yeah or ah there's some guy in punjab in
india
and that's why we're one of the only
religions and it's one thing i respect
about
catholicism only in this regard or
orthodox christianity is they have the
reliance on their tradition they're not
sola scriptura right so they have
their church fathers and things to
interpret these things and the same well
we're
we're a lot better at it obviously we
have a much uh i think uh
more um uh valid tradition but you know
we have we are a religion of tradition
we are a religion of tradition we have
scholars we have people of knowledge to
help us
and there's too many muslims today who
both on the so-called conservative angle
even the liberal angle who reject that
tradition
who think that they don't need it in
order to interpret the quran and the sun
and it's like no that's not how it goes
yeah okay the the prophet the
the the scholars are the heirs of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
and if you don't understand that then
you need to go back and relearn some
things
i mean what would you what would you do
with zakat i mean
i could give two dollars i could give a
pound in charity and say
there it is i i gave my zakat i'm done
right so without hadith
how how do you do any of this right
so thank you for that question beckham
newman um i don't think we could have
had such a fruitful
uh outcome would you still hear me i
think it matter a lot
without you mumbling we the whole point
here is to learn and so people are
making these claims
and martial are beautiful responsible
for you too anything you want to add
support to that particular topic
no i'm just saying richard yeah what do
you want to
[Laughter]
i'm just surprised you read moby dick
that
that many times
i actually like the book yeah i'm sorry
i i i told brothers
on the arena please be on the original
apologies
the the the moby dick i got from the
library when i was done with it
it actually looked like it had been
through a sea storm
because i've taken it to camp with me
yeah really i had taken it to camp with
me i left it outside the tent by
accident it started raining it was a
real struggle for me to
to get through so and at the end i had
to discard it and just pay the library
the fee
but uh no i admire brother assad then
that just goes to show that sometimes
things are worth a second read because
uh you know
well no but if you've read it one time
right and you know the outcome
how i don't understand how you could
read it again knowing what's going to
happen
uh vhs tapes and we used to watch the
same film 10 times
i was going to say people watching
movies twice yeah i know but you know
reading a book it's like me
you know when i was good i read the lord
of the rings and the hobbit and all that
yeah
but i only read it because i want to see
what happens
who doesn't know what happens
um as i was trying to tell us about
earlier
in that comment section there's much
more to moby dick in the story it's
actually
full of a lot of symbolism so for
example there's a whole chapter in there
on the anatomy of a whale and it's sort
of like in the middle
of the book like it doesn't make much
sense like why is it there
and the reality is it's because it's a
symbol
of talking about god's attributes
because moby dick plays the role of god
as a metaphor
so captain ahab is like the atheist who
who hates god
and wants to take down god through his
own nufs
so that's why he could be worth a second
read because yeah i could be like whoa i
totally did not see that the first time
let me have a second read to see
what what that's the same one with the
movie in the white whale yeah
okay maybe just i thought it was just
the guy who has his
ambition to catch this particular whale
no everything is is
there's a there's a meaning behind
everything because um herman melville
was uh very he traveled a lot he was
very learned individual
um in terms of his experiences and he
wanted to sort of explain modern society
and religion and politics through moby
dick
oh wow yeah you don't get that you don't
catch that in the movie though
no no no this is geezer after a while it
reminds me of orca
all right let's see what we got right
this one i can't work out
what he's about middle east is not
something our middle east is not white
elohim
this has been a diverse hamza's den so
far
we're waiting for we're just waiting for
someone to come that's like tried out
second psychedelics or something
i think i think that's what's going to
mix things up yeah or you know weaker
anyone want to discuss i've got a
beautiful guest waiting for you guys man
um get ready for him let's just see what
ray's all about
yeah mate welcome ray you muted me
ray ray
anyone remove remove
no james that's got to be done it's got
to be done
he's just so pathetic though
where's your camera on man we want to
see that lovely hair man yeah he's just
like
coming to the park coming to the park
let me just introduce the audience this
little scumbag here
comes to the park by every single
person in the park including there's
scrutofenix pigeons that hang around
then decides the only way i'm going to
get famous is by coming to the park and
trying to burn the quran
when he fails at that attempt then
we refuse to engage him and then you can
watch this video
actually if you go back a few days but
he tries to interrupt a conversation
between myself and some atheists right
and in the middle of the conversation he
interrupts
and i actually school him there and then
i'll tell him listen uh i'm not going to
talk to you and i haven't explained to
the atheist look i'm going to be very
nice to you guys i'm being nice to you
guys but this guy i'm not being nice to
you
this guy tried to burn the quran and he
still hung around like a bad smell
and the guy is now coming here we're not
going to throw you any crumbs
james and what you need to realize is if
you want to have a civil dialogue we're
ready to have that
but if you're going to try and burn the
quran disrespect our book
we're not going to be charitable and
give you any crumbs
okay so here's what we'll do tonight can
i clarify something real quick regarding
his
did he feel it actually burning like he
couldn't burn it like he couldn't make a
fire
was he sitting like it's not working
mate
you know well um if you go back
online uh the new uh whatever the news
was there's something like
the police stopped him or something like
this it's just something really silly
but the thing but the thing with people
like james is that when you lose a
debate
fair enough you lose a debate then to
try and
you know oh i know how to be famous that
american
pastor burnt the quran let me try and do
that as well
it's just so petty you're such an
immigrant
i want to use you're an intellectual
peasant
you're an intellectual peasant
let's do this let's do this if james is
willing to come on and apologize for
that stunt
we'll hear his nonsense point today do
you know what he's going to do
look can i predict what he's going to do
can i predict him he's not going to
apologize instead he's
going to say is do you condemn us
apostasy in islam apostasy is worse
than actually burning the quran so it's
going to be the one about it
james i'll give you one opportunity i'll
bring you one you apologize for this
pathetic stunt
and we'll engage with you if you don't
apologize
have a lovely evening
let's give them some crumbs come on
let's give him some credit
so how about
right i'll say it again to you you're
just going to come on and say either yes
i apologize or no i stand by my nonsense
stunt
so we know not how about it's just an
apology
i'm giving you one opportunity i promise
you then i'm not i'm not actually going
to block you from the studio i'm not
going to kick i'm going to block it
give him 10 seconds all right
okay if we can all agree that
disrespecting religions
is a bad thing to do then i'll
definitely apologize but only if we can
all agree
that disrespecting religions is a bad
thing to do
you don't apologize about in koran
though why no no no
i'm i'm willing to apologize like i'll
say
kind of disrespectful let me tell you
the farthest thing you've fallen into
you've fallen into the fallacy of what
about islam
no james all right we have to do it this
way
bring him back first so i'm going to
bring it back i'm going to let you make
your point because he's interrupting
no no bring him back let's slap him up a
bit yeah he can hear you
what you've done is you're basically
saying and i know your line of reasoning
well islam does islam disrespects
religion so i can either well you have
to understand that's the what about
islam fallacy
if you're going to come here and try and
have a discussion on the muslim panel
let me first tell you something yeah
you're groveling for our attention
you've entered our arena it's our rules
here you little boy
so what's gonna happen is if you turn up
here we despite when we feed you
we decide when we don't feed you and i
think hamza we're gonna stop feeding
this little scrippinic pigeon and he can
go back to his
existential crisis of not really having
any social media clout
which is causing him to have a type of
depression
all right goodbye ray
are you gonna try
i'm well yourself oh wow you said that
like
yeah i'm fantastic mate um thanks for
having me so uh you want me to start out
with my point i
um just a heads up i did put my links in
the back chat before i came on so i
don't have to back out
and put them in so uh my point
is that uh there's a ruling
that um
that the quran is not supposed to be
recited some verses
on certain stipulations and that muslims
are still
reciting those and i want to know why
what so you basically you you said
in in the quran it says this you're
saying no no
muhammad said in the hadith and i have
the hadith that's the first link i
posted
that if there is a uh
if there is a different meaning of
interpretation that muslims should stop
reciting
that part of the quran so why are
muslims still reciting parts of the
quran
that there is different interpretations
if you're supposed to follow muhammad
and obey him
and as the judge why are you reciting
parts of the quran that uh
still to this day have uh
interpretation and meaning difference
give me an example
so in those links i gave a couple
uh one the the better ones
would be like the attributes of allah
like hands um uh the verses with hands
shins i believe that's the second one
that it mentions the attributes of allah
now there's muslims to this day that do
not believe that it is
would be such as oh well they're
misguided or
they're not true muslims that doesn't
really answer the question
because the meaning and interpretation
that muhammad said
said to stop reciting it until it is
determined upon
well it's still not determined upon
across the whole um
all right one second right one second
right i'm going to be honest with you
anger could be talking about does
anybody recognize what he's on about
i have the links in the backchat
um so what you're basically saying i'm
just trying to understand
is that we shouldn't recite something
that has multiple interpretations
that is no that's not what it says it
says
that if the interpretation is not agreed
upon
now that's different than the way that
you said it right because the way you're
saying it is
multiple interpretations that's true it
would be multiple
but the way muhammad phrased it is that
if it is not
agreed upon on the interpretation then
you should not recite that quran
that verse until it is agreed upon
so i want to know why muslims are
reciting these verses look um ray
um i don't know what you're actually
talking about and i don't think you know
never take one quranic verse or one
particular narration and run away with
it
in the quran it actually says about some
verses that the ambiguous
meaning we let you speak so you're going
to let me speak because it's our arena
um so you're gonna have to behave
yourself there um what it is is that
we don't take a particular narration or
a particular verse of the quran and then
say
okay so this is one maxim which
undermines anything else
so i've just given you one example from
the quran but the quran is clear
that actually some verses are
ambiguous and none seek the meaning of
it and give it its own interpretation
except for those with
certain types of hearts and one knows
the true meaning except allah
yeah so wait one second one second let
me just complete my point uh no need to
you know jump in there so there's
nothing you can do
to bring one particular quranic verse or
one particular hadith and then say
therefore we cannot actually uh recite
this and i
find this hilarious from a christian
who you don't even have a single verse
talking about
i'm not jesus yourself in terms of the
bible and
i find that kind of hilarious because i
already answered your question but
i i would be very happy to hear that
you're here trying to nitpick about
interpretations of a particular verse
and why
muslims shouldn't actually recite them
yet you cannot give me a single
verse of a single uh line that you can
attribute to jesus
going back in a testimonial way that
muslims actually do
yet you're here trying to nitpick on a
small nuanced
trivial
are you a christian ray no we talk to
you you're not christian
we talked about this two weeks ago so
ray i
have no idea who you are uh what what
are you
what do you believe yes
so firstly sabira just made two points
that are not true firstly about me he
tried to say that i'm a christian
without even knowing anything about me
because he's trying to divert the topic
can somebody please screen share the
hadith where
that i gave you is the first link with
the name
ray under it now if you screen share
that and let the audience
read it they will understand that if you
are supposed to obey
muhammad as they say right that he is
the judge
to make the judge amongst you it says in
this
that uh if there is any discrepancy
like in interpretation or meaning that
the muslims are not allowed to
actually recite this verse
this hadith you're quoting this hadith
you're quoting
have you seen a scholars understanding
of it
there's three of them in sanhui bukhari
alone
have you seen a scholars understanding
of it ray you put up
okay sorry i did i thought you were
christian because there's somebody in
the chat
i mistake him for you that's been king
the links you've been putting up are the
verses of the quran
i'm not sure
so that's not true what you just said
again is not true
so can you attack can you focus on the
argument please before can you post the
link again
i'd have to back out of my phone and out
of this session let me i already read
the habit so i just need to ask
the argument that if muslims disagree
in general on a specific ayah of the
quran
and in terms of its interpretation we
are no longer allowed to recite it
indefinitely is that the good note
the chapter heading is recite the quran
together as long as you agree about its
interpretation
and then the narration goes on to say
recite and study the quran as long as
you agree about it
but if you have any difference of
opinion regarding it you should stop
resigning for the time being
and this is in context of a group
recitation so it's not in context of oh
when the entire
ummah decides to agree upon it then we
can all start reciting it again in our
prayers or something
like i don't even know can you provide
me with can you provide me the evidence
that that is
the uh the correct meaning of this
hadith
but that doesn't really mean that
doesn't really mean that you're tackling
the
question right because just don't worry
about what
secondary one second rate what's the
second rate
and i'll repeat it once again is recite
the quran together
as long as you agree about its
interpretation so it's in context of a
group recitation like when
if we're all reciting together in a
group what i would like to add to that
ray
what i would like to add to that ray is
that
is that in the the part about
interpretation
that is an interpretation in the english
translation of the hadith the word
interpretation
is not there in the arabic so it says
i'll just read it
what combines or joins or connects your
hearts
that your hearts connect
if you differ over it then uh refrain
from it i.e refrain from reciting it so
it's not it there's nothing about
interpretation here per se
so this could be in the context of as
brother assad allah said let's say group
recitation
and someone is making a mistake in the
quran out of three people
they they don't remember it or something
like this but this the point is there's
nothing about interpretation in that
hadith
i know it's the english even in the
english it's in the brackets if you
noticed even in the english it's in the
brackets right
i didn't read the brackets i did bring
up the brackets so
um but that's funny that you would
mention that and the reason i said that
to
uh andalusia project is because uh
about uh can you provide the scholarship
proof is because hamza just asked me
for scholarship proof about what this
hadith means
so it's funny how when a muslim speaks
he doesn't need that
that scholarship proof but when i speak
he needs it now i can tell
rey ray ready ray let me answer that
that's actually fallacious because the
reason that i
objected to your interpretation was not
on the basis of whether or not you had
scholarly
backing it was the fact that your
interpretation doesn't even coincide
with the english meaning
so that's not the point that i spoke
about yeah
no the point that you made does not get
to the point that i made about
hamza retorting to me oh okay that's
your personal
that's your personal reasoning and
that's fine i was directing it towards
hamza now if i may speak to sadat
yeah um so why not me i was the first
one effect
yeah because i i just addressed yours
and since i
dressed humbly you well then you're
you're
right right right right i'm not going to
allow you to do what you're trying to do
so as allah give you an explanation
that's why it's referring to group
recitation
do you accept that no no okay then i can
report to that too right because there
are
groups inside of a mosque that are not
always the same belief system such as
how many mosques
that's the reason you see different
muslims pray different ways because they
ray how many mosques have you visited
and heard people congregationally
reciting the prayer
how many more listen to the question
listen to the question
i've never been to one mosque where i've
heard multiple recitation of the quran
by loads of different people
i haven't been to anywhere so which
mosque have you been to ray where you've
witnessed
muslims reciting the quran together
where have you been i haven't i haven't
been to a mosque sir
you've never been to a mall it's like
one second
gave an explanation he doesn't want to
accept it which is fine
that's fine if he doesn't want to accept
a logical answer but
the question i have for him is what
conclusion do you make from that
like okay fine let's just say you're
right muslims are not supposed to recite
something they don't agree about
what is your categorical conclusion from
that so firstly once again you said
something that's not true that i did not
accept his answer
you are not waiting for me to speak
sabir i appreciate that
now let me speak to sadat real quick
because he used
he tried to give ray i'm not going to
let you do it just yet you can come to
saddam in a minute
i'm not going to allow you to say things
i i want to be clear that i think that
brother sadat brought up a good point
regarding no no
no no no he can respond to him but i
don't like it when people say things
like
in the mosques they're doing this that
the other but you've never been to a
mosque
and marshall i've been a muslim 20 years
and i've been to so many messages
alhamdulillah
and i've never heard what you're
claiming happens in mosques so i'm
trying to understand
i'm trying to understand what is the
source of your information that this
happens
so may i have two two minutes unless
even less
the point about the mosque is you even
see people praying in different stance
because they are
from different mod hops right they pray
ray i'm not gonna allow you me it's not
gonna happen
you're gonna you're gonna stay on point
right what's the point you want me to
stay up okay
you made a claim that in mosques
multiple people are reciting the quran
together where'd you get the information
from
so because most people do recite the
quran in their prayer
where'd you get this information from
that they're reciting together aloud
where are you getting this from
no i never said that it was allowed who
said it's all out
when did i say that you said you said in
mosques
you said in mosques they recite the
quran together
and i'm asking you since you've never
been to a mosque
where's that information from so here's
the thing
because it's true that while they are
recite
while the imam is reciting the quran uh
like
al-fatiha for example muslims are
also reciting it inside of either their
minds or with their lips
this all right so recycling with the
imam
is there a difference of opinion on
interpretation of surah fatiha
no but that's not that's not the issue
here
with regards to okay so you've never
been to a mars see what i'm
demonstrating here ray
you're waffling you're making claims you
can't support
you can't anything you're just saying
things from the sky
no yeah you've never been to a mosque so
you have nothing
wait wait you've never been to a mosque
and witnessed any of this so i'm kind of
confused
where you get your information from so
when i watch when i
watch videos of muslims in france going
to the streets and blocking streets and
that they are using microphones and that
they're all
they're all outside praying together i
can make an assumption right
no
[Music]
okay can i add a couple of points here
because you have to
understand the basic principle when
muslims play in congregation is the imam
who's
reciting not everyone that it wasn't
i never firstly muslims are supposed to
recite
themselves but quietly that's even
insane
does somebody want to jump in and say if
i'm misquoting the quran that allah says
that uh to recite quietly where did it
say to reciting congregation
well the quran actually says that you're
supposed to uh
that you're only supposed to pray in
groups three or four
so no where does it say to reciting
congregation
why are you done
yeah i'm exposing you for a waffler
because you're saying things that you've
got no support for no
substantiation for you're just saying
things
anyway anyway i think that point has
been demonstrated you're waffling on
that point you've never been to a mosque
you don't know what goes on in a mosque
you're just assuming in your mind
definition of waffling that's not the
definition of waffling
yeah you yes you yes if i looked in a
dictionary of waffling it'll say rey
so yeah you okay anyway responders are
that
so saddam ray maybe maybe i'll just hear
your question first and then i just
wanted to share a couple of
points that might be helpful or or they
might not but do you want to ask your
question first i mean
yes sir thank you sadat so when you
uh gave me your translation which is
fine we'll go with your translation
even though i do have problems with
people
doing translations that are not like
peer reviewed right
i do not really okay okay yeah yeah just
saying but i'll concede to your
translation
now if you will give it to me again you
said in their hearts to heart
i just because it's been a few minutes
so i want to double check that i'm not
quoting you before i bring my argument
means to combine to bring together to
connect
that's one of the verbs that is used
there yeah okay
so to the point that i was making about
inside of mosque you do have
multiple uh belief systems inside of
islam
right it's not like exclu mosques do not
exclude people due to their mod hobs or
their belief systems
did you just say mosques might exclude
no no no they do not
they do nothing did they say they don't
do
they do not they do they do not okay
you're correct yeah
yes sir so that that's where i'm leading
up to and then i'm going with
like the verses of the shin right which
are supposed to the attributes of allah
are supposed to be literal now uh
you will have people reciting verses in
the quran and it's totally possible
that they recite these verses right
together and they and there may be
people
who do not have the literal
interpretation
of the attributes of allah inside of
that same group
of resuscita reciting so would that not
be applied to this hadith
okay i get you i understand your
question right and
uh i i just want to share three very
general basic points with you
these are not meant to crush you or
expose you
i i genuinely just want to share three
thoughts with you
and please take them with an open mind
please take them with an open heart
and you don't even have to you don't
even have to respond to it here i'm not
going to
put you down if you don't have an answer
or if you don't have a response
i genuinely want you to think about
these three points sincerely when you
leave okay
number one you're correct that there are
different madhhabs
different madahib that have different
legal interpretations
of some of the verses of the quran and
of the interpretation of the hadith
you're correct in this
but notice that none of these madhhab
says
that you are not allowed to recite from
the quran
if muslims disagree about the
interpretation of that particular verse
in other words
despite the ichthyolaf despite the
differences amongst them
this is not one of those differences
they all agree
that the quran it is going to have
different different interpretations
whether we like it or not
that should not stop that does not stop
you from reciting the quran
okay now your question might be well
then what about that hadith
because in that hadith the prophet
muhammad apparently peace be upon him he
is saying
that if you have a difference of
interpretation about a verse then don't
recite that verse
just leave it right so that is where i'm
bringing to your attention
i i respect the fact that you have a
problem with ad hoc
translations that are not peer reviewed
that's fine
so i i i invite you to just look
into this i will give you the root
letters of the two verbs that are used
in that
hadith okay so one is if you want to
write this down
if you if you have to look it up in
arabic dictionary even with the
with that for the aid of a muslim friend
or with the aid of a christian arab
friend the root letters there
are uh that would and someone can
correct me if i'm wrong
alif lam and that's
like a a l f alif
look up the eighth look up the eighth uh
form of that verb it's means to
to combine or to link or to connect verb
number two that's used in that
is it says that if they differ if they
continue to to
uh to to differ uh then they should uh
refrain from it or they should stop that
verb there for differ
is the root verbs are
okay which doesn't have an english
letter equivalent like k-h
so my point is what's my point in all of
this to summarize my point
rey is that there is no word that i see
there in the arabic hadith i don't see
it
i don't see any word there that says
anything about interpretation
it says that if you continue to differ
over it
then stop but differ over what differ
over its recitation
or differ over over its pronunciation
or differ over its interpretation
there's no reason to
interpret that it says interpretation
because my friend
that word interpretation is not there in
the arabic
and finally the third point is a bit of
a random one which is that when you said
that in the quran it says you should
only
recite or pray or something like that in
groups of three or four
my friend please investigate and see if
the quran actually says that
and if it doesn't say that that means
that you know maybe you shouldn't be
making assumptions about the quran or
speaking authoritatively about the quran
if you don't know
right or maybe it is there in which case
i don't know in which case i should
apologize and
uh plead to my ignorance on that point
you know so may i address your second
point
thanks for listening great yeah yeah
please so um
so to your third point i'm
positive that it says that now uh
next time i come on here i'll start i'll
open with that verse
and then that way go find it go go ray
ray ray go google it i'll bring you back
on don't worry
okay so i just wanted to address the
second point real quick
and for a second i want you to address
that point go
go go see you in a minute i just want to
ask where a question though
yeah and atheists do this and james does
something similar to this
they stick on a small benign point and
they just make it and if they made it
successfully
would it mean islam is false would it
mean atheism is true like
i want to understand fine you i mean the
arena is about
exposing each other's fates to scrutiny
so
what's your conclusion and should we all
become
the quran what was it yeah let's just
see let's just accept his argument
hypothetically
should we all become an atheist i mean
what's he doing i wanted to come back
i wanted to come back and say oh no it's
not there it's like
wrong the whole thing there is there is
that but the thing is i also found that
look if you look at the way someone's
speaking
you see when muslims are when i see them
praying and blocking the road and he's
chucking in certain things
he's thinking something so i want to
know is this
what is the actual implication of what
he's saying
if he's right is islam wrong is atheism
correct
because i sometimes find people like him
and james and others they're so pedantic
about these small issues and they think
this basically means something oh i've
won on a tiny little
astronomically small point therefore
nothing
like literally nothing it doesn't
actually mean anything yeah because
my question my question would be a very
simple one if this
how would each muslim know who
interprets what which verses
am i gonna go right i'm planning to say
something
in my salat today um could everyone tell
me how they
what is the practicalities of it i don't
even understand it and i just read the
hadith again in it from another source
and it doesn't just say about recite
about uh interpret it talks about
studying it
so is it
the proof of how well arena's working
and how well
established islam is online that these
atheists pathetically have to go
and literally go find narrations that
we've never heard of
well i've never heard of obviously i
said alone that did yeah
and then literally just be like okay let
me just try in this small pathetic
argument it's like well all of those
things you could bring up that all these
other atheists have been bringing up
which has been smashed
out of the park they've now given up and
now they literally go and find these
uh particular things which are so benign
and they just try and win some little
victory from it
yeah sabur i like your approach that's
actually a great you know reminder to me
to
to to pause and ask people like okay
what exactly are the ramifications of
everything that you just said if
everything you said was true
does it prove islam false what is your
point if i had to venture a guess
it's to try to place strange kind of
doubts in people or
if i had to venture a guess i guess he
would say that the implications are
you can't recite the quran out loud
publicly you can't recite it okay
because even invariably muslims will
have some different interpretations
therefore the quran you can't do your
congregational prayers
you can't do your juma prayer which is
which is a pretty ludicrous
idea the idea that every muslim missed
this right every muslim missed this
and sorry just one more point the same
that he references
as an example of differing views not one
of them has this view
that you're the muslims are not allowed
to recite the quran if there's any
difference of
interpretation of that verse yeah
i mean it's basically like this right
we're supposed to be coming on to the
arena
and the whole point of the arena is like
the gladiators you come in you come in
with your arguments
everyone gets the battering eventually
someone walks out alive
now we're here ready
and ray turns up and sets off a little
firecracker and gets lost
bring something solid bring something
that if it was successful
it would do damage to the religion of
islam not just you know a little squeaky
noise a mouse makes and then
you know that that's you're supposed to
be a point that's what i'm thinking
bring him back
let's see what his implications yeah
well he's gone google it i've sent him
off to go google
what um he was asked to do to find in
the quran where it says we have to pray
in threes and fours
and um i've got to bring this guy on
because his name is who is hamza um
saying something i just want to say real
quick back on that point of the pedantry
i agree with that in that i've noticed
that a lot of atheists and christians et
cetera especially like to bring up these
pedantic arguments
uh things on the periphery of our
religion in order to
try to prove us wrong which is to me is
indicative that they can't deal with the
central principles of our faith the
central arguments of our faith
you know so that showcases how weak
their intellectual you know
whereas we typically deal with the
central
you know arguments that christianity and
a lot of atheists make
we go into you know their philosophy
into their metaphysical naturalism into
their scientism and things like this
and then they think they think that you
know this is all mental gymnastics
because it takes a long time for us to
explain things and talk about these
things and complex it and then they come
on here well what about this hadith that
nobody else has read
it's like yeah it's like or something
you know what i mean like you know
that's that's their that's the best they
can do
also yeah sorry one more thing too is
like i also noticed this as well
it's like and i and i i agree with
brother sada in terms of the nuance of
the arabic language and what was really
being
stated there however every time they
bring up a hadith
whether it's rob or some other person on
here i just look at the english
translation i'm like even in english
like it makes no sense do you not
understand your own mother tongue
we're all immigrants we can understand
english but not all of us here
but we can all understand english better
than half these people bringing up this
stuff i don't understand that it makes
no sense to me
sorry that's where i would cut him just
a little bit of slack in the sense that
when you just look at that english
translation then it did say that
if they differ about its interpretation
uh then they should
stop reciting and so that translation
itself is is very very problematic but
if he has a problem with my ad hoc
translation which is not peer reviewed
we have every right to have a problem
with his interpretation which is not
peer reviewed
right what scholar gave his
interpretation what scholar ever
endorsed that interpretation that hey
if there's a verse of the quran that
muslims have ever differed over in terms
of its
interpretation that's it we're not
allowed to recite that verse publicly
anymore
um anyhow he tried he tried yeah and you
know and they say things like in mosques
they do this and then
oh yeah muslim countries this happens
and you know how many muslim countries
you visited
oh um not really none oh muslim women
are treated this way in that way how
many muslim women have you spoken to
yeah i mean
you know what's interesting about these
types of people is that
their very breath stinks of islamophobia
like literally in his
in his hatred of islam he cannot contain
himself
except to bring up one benign point
which he doesn't want to discuss
anything else to discuss that benign
point
but within it he'll say things like oh
my muslims are blocking the roads
and you can tell a lot that there's a
lot in the voice there's a lot in the
mannerisms
there's a lot in these types of things
and these types of characters
they are the types of people that you
actually have to humiliate
and when you humiliate them then the
other minions which are watching
on the sidelines um they actually
understand that actually if i try this
then i'm also going to get battered
that's why it's important for anybody
that comes into the arena
come with something solid or you're
going to go with your bags packing
[Laughter]
he's been waiting for ages and then he
comes under that so this matty proponent
well he's the only one left in the back
chat what's the script with him
should we just slap him about a bit
well actually
[Applause]
just
do you understand what the stream is
about
uh the arena yes i've kind of uh
understood that you
have to uh bring out the claim
or something that is uh you have a point
that is
you want to clarify so you you know you
are the
i'll tell you the third rule of the
arena
no muslims
it wouldn't be fair because we always
kick muslims off because um
this is for non-muslims opportunity to
come on and challenge us
and it's embarrassing that they're
crying in the comment section and says
where are they
where are they april april there's a
girl called april right he's always
banging on about atheism and that
always threatening to come onto the
arena the backstage is yours
there's no there's no one waiting the
arena's i mean i think the caliber of
the guests today so kind of like
you scared them all away points do you
do you think matthew can you pretend not
to know something at
some point just like just kind of like i
think he was a girl
stumble over the answer like oh i don't
know
oh oh yes hey
smith's in the house the lord jesus
praise the lord jesus hallelujah are you
okay
i'm happy you're here thank you what
point you're passing on today
sorry i'm just greeting my little my
lord and savior jesus christ
what point you want bashing on today can
i say that
you say that the trinity doesn't make
sense there's all here see
this and that and the other next but
christianity is a large religion in the
world
but of the past two thousand years so
how can everyone else get it but you
don't
okay can i ask you a very easy question
do you believe catholics are christians
yeah you do yeah they believe jesus died
on the cross and they believe that he's
the son of god
yeah that makes you christian right so
according to orthodox christianity well
the catholics are
not christians according to the you
you're you're uh you're a protestant in
it
i'm a i'm a pentecostal president right
so you don't recognize catholicism as
true christianity
oh you shouldn't i believe the bible
says truly if you believe
that the lord jesus is the son of god
and he down the cross you were saved
so no but no but you the proponents of
your belief system
don't recognize catholics as christians
i'm saying
i'm going by what the bible says not by
anything else so you're not going by
so you're not going by the proponents of
your okay fair enough
everything else is everything else is
extra
but but the but the the point so just
just to understand your point
you're saying christianity is bigger
than more more numerous than islam yeah
no i'm saying that you're saying that
you like
you guys don't understand the trinity
you're saying this nonsense and it's
made up but what i'm saying is
2.4 billion people today believe like
understanding
okay how come you don't understand it
how can you oh okay
can you can you explain to me how the
people of south america came to the
understanding
of um trinity it's a fallacious argument
to begin with but
i know i know i know i don't know
you don't know how the south america
became all these christians
how do all these christians appear in
south america
i don't know you you don't actually know
you you are
you never heard of the term
conquistadors no i haven't
oh you've never i'm going to leave my
brother to tell you all about the
conquistadors well i think that's
that's not really i mean yeah i mean of
course the computer oh no he needs to
know that a little bit of history
inquisition which started actually in
andalus
actually the reconquista which is where
they got their name conquistadors
um was that they basically committed
genocide against
mass populations and re converted them
to christianity
uh which is why spain is now primarily
catholic and my
ancestors are all dead or ran away to
morocco
so that's right went all together but
uh the whole argument to begin with is
actually quite boricious i mean uh
it doesn't say this
what i'm asking is do you understand the
concept of the trinity do you understand
trinity i do but the thing is uh my
argument against you would be in
response to that and aside from the
the fallacious nature of the argument
that oh there's so many christians
therefore they must understand it better
than everyone else
or they must understand it but we don't
because there's an enormous amount of
them
well i mean during the nice scene why is
it so popular for the past two thousand
years
christianity has been the largest
religion in the whole universe
okay uh well kind of about a 600 year
head start
so anyways the so what i was trying to
make as well is that during the nice
council the
church fathers at the time were arguing
amongst themselves about how to
interpret
and understand it so according to you on
the basis of that alone
why is it that they had trouble
understanding it during that council and
had to come to an agreement on certain
things
and therefore does that mean that the
earliest church fathers were also
you know they had a problem themselves
with comprehending
the religion because they you know did
they they had to argue over for a very
long time
before they came to conclusions about
how to define it so
the people who are closest to the
original teachings according to
i believe you know christian historians
why is it that they had to actually come
together
and argue with each other until they've
gotten over these definitions
that we have today well
you're you guys are in the same position
because that's what um the
the earliest muslims did they they had
you know different interpretations of
the koran
so you guys have to say are are saying
you know
well i'm saying that that people
understand it more because there are
more people
that doesn't make any sense because then
you're basically arguing that
i mean no but no trouble with it before
no
i'm trying to say understanding it then
then they had a less understanding of it
than
the people after them i mean no but you
guys are saying no oh
it doesn't no one's saying this you guys
are saying that it doesn't make sense or
you know
at least so many people believe it so
many people believe it today
but that doesn't matter how many how
many people believe muhammad was a
prophet
um aaron how many people what you mean
muslims
yeah yeah one point eight billion
whatever
does that make it true no i'm not saying
that but what i'm saying is
you're betting on that 0.2 billion
difference
as your criterion for judging the truth
right you're saying you're saying that
the number of christians officially
is more outstrips that of muslims so
that makes the trinity
comprehensible or or logical i mean is
that
the argument that's also in the
assumption that like for i would never
argue for example that
the vast majority of muslims in the
world are somehow uh
super knowledgeable about fick just
because there are so many muslims
compared to islamophobes
but they're very there are so many
muslims living in the villages in random
places in
in the muslim world who only know like
mohammed
know how to pray five times a day but
couldn't tell you like
like even intermediate akita or
intermediate fick or anything
like i'm not going to argue i'm not
going to make that argument in the same
way
that oh because there's so many
christians that somehow they understand
this massive
the complex doctrine that obama's
aquinas had to write volumes on
just for somebody to comprehend yeah
i mean but do you but do you understand
the concept of the of the trinity hamza
do you understand that do you understand
it on hamster yeah
you don't understand it you don't
understand it's noob
who told you i'll tell you why you don't
understand it who told you i don't
understand it oh
okay who is the only true god according
to jesus
there's only one god in three persons
that's it who is the only true god
who is the only true god according to
jesus
the father the father the father the the
the creator
and who is the christian
so who is the only true god then the
father yes the father
as a whole yeah right and what does the
word only mean
only me he's it means the the only
the singular hymn only that means
without exception
without anything else without anyone
without exception meaning
nobody else so jesus's name the only
true god
is the father okay
you came in saying praise jesus and you
didn't say praise the father isn't that
what you're supposed to be doing it but
what i'm trying to say is they are one
one god
no no no jesus says according to your
scripture
jesus says so the people may know
you are the only true god and jesus whom
you have
and jesus of whom you have sent so the
only true god is the father
do you believe jesus is the father let
me ask you a question first no
you answer my question do you believe
jesus is the father
jesus says when you see me you see the
father do you believe
jesus is the father he is
he is the yes he is yeah he is the
father
he is so when jesus is walking on the
earth are you saying this is the father
walking on the earth
yes that's right right you do know this
is
heresy yeah you do know you've just fell
outside all the things
one second you've just learned
of your 2.4 billion christian fellowship
because what you're saying is heresy
it's modernism
the idea that the father becomes the son
the this
is not christianity exactly yeah irony
is uh
young welsh that the the two billion i
think you said two billion the two
billion christians that you were
referencing
as believers in the trinity the vast
majority of them who do actually
uh believe in the trinity who are
religious they would disagree with what
you just said for the reason that hamza
explained
the idea that jesus is the father uh the
the so in other words when you are
referencing these two billion you're
referencing them as if
they have one proper standard orthodox
understanding of the trinity this is not
the case at all
out of this two billion you'll have
difficulty finding two that even explain
it in the same way
earlier on in this live stream brother
hamza was saying that the reason he
doesn't bring in
two christians at the same time let
alone three christians at the same
time is they'll start debating each
other over the trinity
so it's an act of compassion on hamza's
part that he doesn't do that because
we would be sitting back doing nothing
literally we could bring in a christian
right now
and he could debate the next half an
hour with you uh proving to you
or arguing to you why jesus is not the
father
jesus christ the son is distinct from
the father
so do you just i understand just so i
understand so you believe the father was
on the cross
listen okay answer my question the
father do you believe that i do believe
that the father needs to know
i'm asking you the question right i'm
asking you the question because
i answered your question no no you
answered it but no no no
you answered the question but there's
ramifications now to your answer
so you believe the father is jesus so
when jesus is on the cross that's the
father yeah
according to your position
he was um on the cross and he was also
in heaven so the father is on the cross
now yes
at the same time that's right on the
cross would you
say my father has forsaken me he's
talking to himself on the cross
that's right 100 percent well he is the
father
she gets a funny hell of a drug you know
why do you know why no no
no how does how does that work hamster
one second one second
then how does it work when jesus is
saying that they may know you the only
true god and and jesus
as well as jesus whom you have sent now
according to your principle
jesus is the father so who's he talking
to
jesus was what jesus was referring to
himself
who are you talking to when he says they
may know you who's he talking to him
his glorified self in heaven how he
does not understand this you know he's
on earth yeah but he could be in many
places at once do you understand
that's how he works praise the lord
jesus that's how he works
the father so when the father's on earth
he's also in heaven
that's right amen hallelujah who told
you that
no no thank you jesus who told you that
the bible praise the lord where does the
bible say that
the bible says that the father is the
creator
oh no where does the no no no no no
no let me oh my god no
the father is the creator of the of the
universe
so when john what john chapter 1 verse
10 says
and he was in the world and the world
was made by him jesus he jesus made the
world
because he said the father you said the
father in the incarnation
even okay okay he was in heaven and
earth at the same time
if everyone's doing the same thing
what's the point of differentiating them
exactly this is
gosh they yeah listen
okay i'm just gonna keep playing myself
[Music]
i mean after that point i just don't see
the point of the
carrying on like honestly all right okay
okay
just respond to that one point just that
point
[Music]
which point the mic drop which dropped
on your head and made you forget and the
point is
if they all are doing something they are
the same people
well yeah obviously yeah one one god did
he hear israel
the lord is one okay so young welsh when
when jesus prayed and said
father remove this cup from me but not
uh not not
my will but your will what he meant was
not
according to my will but according to my
will
is is that what he meant he has he has a
will in heaven
can he has a human soul as well
i get it no i get it so not according to
my will here on earth
not my earthly self will but my divine
heavenly self will is that right the
alpha prayer says
alphabet watson who was in heaven how
would be thy name thy kingdom come down
but i will be then
thy kingdom come that will be done on
earth
whose will on earth is your will your
will
why your will when it's him world in
heaven and the will on earth
are two different wills but they can act
as one okay
um you're just making stuff up okay so
i'm uh are you accusing god of using
tautologies
what do you mean tautology is when you
say the same thing
it's like saying roses are roses
heaven and earth are two different
places yes
so therefore they have two different
wills what are you talking about
what sorry what are you talking what is
that drink you're having you know you're
just confused right now
i don't drink alcohol praise the lord
jesus
it's very good i thought i thought you
said you only follow the bible so
where did you get no alcohol from didn't
jesus turn water into wine
non-alcoholic why yes praise the lord
jesus oh i didn't know it said that in
john non-alcoholic wine right
well jesus wasn't he didn't drink
obviously
why is that obvious to you
because saint paul confirmed it why did
saint paul confirm it
our beloved saint paul confirmed that
drunkenness is is sin
yeah drunkenness is something when you
remember when paul met jesus in his
uh when he was at this party when he was
visited yes
no was was was paul at the party where
jesus turned the water to wine
you didn't he he didn't have to be there
no he didn't have to be all didn't have
to be there
no so paul didn't have to be there but
paul knew that at that party jesus
didn't drink wine
that's right through the holy ghost
praise lord jesus through the holy ghost
that's right the holy ghost thank you
lord jesus oh my god
well
it's like honestly you started talking
different modalities
these guys where did they come from bro
bro
this is i'll be honest with you bro
right you're going to the list
we've risked all the people who think
i'm not joking the people who came with
you know proper
arguments here they've been mashed up
you're not hiring people to do this are
you are you i feel like this
are these are these are these like
actors but raise back raise back
the whole thing but i always want to
make a point too about that the
pragmatic argument that about and what's
the point of having all these different
uh you know modalities and let's say you
do have different modalities like for
example in an abstract sense yes i'm a
father
i'm a husband uh i have a certain status
of employment i'm a citizen i'm this i'm
that
right but i don't need to name them all
differently and act like they're
different separate aspects
of my own existence right like you know
it's like you know the attributes of
allah we don't say that his attributes
are different people
with different names like he goes by
those different names because that's
that's that's who it is you know these
are aspects
of his uh what is it his actions
in the world you know this is so these
these attributes that are shown to us
are
explained to us are essentially um i
don't get too deep into it but
the point i'm trying to make is like why
is like i said why does god in the
christian religion have to have
completely separate personas in order to
manifest attributes that the father
himself should have by himself without
any
you know yeah it's like oh here's my son
he has aspects of me that i don't really
have but i do have
and it's like come down yourself then
bro
but here's the thing you see he did come
down himself
that's what he said he talked to himself
he's down here and he's pointing that's
his
sword so using your example in other
words
assad the brother doesn't have
conversations with assad the father and
i said the father
doesn't pray to us at the sun right it's
yeah that'd be weird yeah he would be
mentally ill
[Music]
all right ray's back he's going to come
with the verse of the quran where it
says to pray in congregation
oh in threes and fours
okay thanks for having me back on i'll
admit that i was wrong i was looking at
[Applause]
hey hey uh me finish so i was reading uh
i was trying to off the top of my head
go with uh
surah 73 verse 20 where it says
groups and then right after the sentence
is a third
or two-thirds of the night that muhammad
stays up with his group
so that i can admit when i'm wrong dude
there's nothing wrong with that
admitting that you're wrong no no it's
brilliant it is fantastic
to admit you're wrong because now we
know
you could be wrong about other things
ray i was half ready to
i was half ready i was half ready to
admit that that i could have been wrong
because i thought i i don't know maybe
i i've overlooked something that you're
going to uh bring up i didn't remember
about praying in threes or fours in the
quran so
that's fine it would have been me it
could have been wrong no it's not
everybody gets things wrongs at
different times you know especially
when you're not reading the source
material right there you know i wasn't
i wasn't trying to do verbatim i was
trying to remember
um yeah so could you bring up your
second point again about my argument
okay look the remaining two points then
very quickly ray were that number one
you referenced the different mudhubs the
different legal schools to show that
there's a wide
array of different interpretations of
the quran and of the hadiths fine
okay what i pointed out to you ray is
that
not one of these madhabs holds
that interpretation that you were giving
of that hadith which is
that if there is a verse of the quran
which people
differ about in regards to its
interpretation
that verse should be dropped from oral
recitation
altogether that verse should never be
recited in a mosque
it should never be recited uh in our
prayers
this interpretation has never been held
by any by any math hub so
if you're sincere my brother then you'll
ask yourself why is it
that i have an interpretation which no
muslim scholar
ever in the history of islam had to you
it's important that my translation of
that hadith be peer reviewed
is it equally important that your
interpretation of that hadith be
peer reviewed by muslim scholars what
muslim ever held to that interpretation
and point point number this is the
important point was number two
that the word interpretation is not
there in the arabic in that hadith
so the hadith could be talking about if
you differ about its recitation
if you differ about its uh pronunciation
but it's not
talking about interpretation that word
is not
there so may i address number two and
then we'll go back to number one
okay so in your second one
i also gave um the kathir
um ibn kathir link for 261 of the quran
it should still be in your back chat it
won't be in mine
but um so in this and i also gave
corporates.quran.com um
uh they do seven different translations
now the word here that is an objection
is boom
okay now
uh one of the curve
so just so i understand so let's just
underline as we go
chapter 261 is the verse you're
referring to yeah
yes okay let me read it
but let me read it and remember when you
said
oh moses we cannot enjoy the same meal
every day
so just call upon your lord on our
behalf he will bring forth
us some of what the earth produces of
herbs cucumbers garlic lentils and
onions
moses scolded them do you exchange what
is better for what is worse
you can go down to any village and you
will find what you have asked for
they were stricken with disgrace and
misery and they invited the displeasure
of allah for rejecting allah's signs
and unjustly killing the prophets this
is a fair reward for their disobedience
and violations
so okay so garlic
is in dispute right because it's foom
now uh if you if you click like let's
say
um the uh corporate.com
dispute what do you mean well i'm just
let me finish
please and so if you check with
corporates.quran.com
there's uh seven different translations
and some of them use
garlic some of them use uh uh what words
may i just speak real quick and
summarize what my position is
so some of them use uh garlic
some of them use corn some of them uh
then one translation i believe is musa
and khan
keeps the word foom in there now the
reason is if you click
uh evan cather's link that i gave for
this
is that even a boss uses the word
before but ready
so i understand what you're doing just
so i understand i could be wrong
are you now given an example of a verse
in the quran that there's different
interpretations of
and you're still applying the meaning to
that hadith which we've just responded
to
are you now giving us are you no
demonstrating this person's in the quran
that has different interpretations is
that what you're doing because this
this goes to his points sadat's point
and then you also mentioned when i got
off that
that you read a different hadith of the
same reading that was head
that was headlined no really right right
right
no no right man yeah right so that just
said to you not one scholar in islamic
history
has interpreted that hadith the way you
have and what you're doing now
you're using that as your premise to
know and find verses of the quran that
have different interpretation
i asked if i could address number two
and then go to number one that was his
first point so if i wait to address the
second
basis because you can't just ignore the
reputation
foundation it's a foundation no it's not
your foundation's fraud
why are you not giving me just like six
i'll tell you why i'm not
because your foundation is flawed right
and what you've just done is ignored
everything that's been said to you
you ignored what assad allah said to you
with regards it's talking about um
praying together
we've already said that doesn't have to
happen and we've already established you
have don't know whether people muslims
pray in mosques together and recite the
quran right
and then so that told you even though we
have different methods not one of them
had this interpretation of this
uh hadith in the way you have it
and what you're doing is wasting
everybody's time and you're just
pressing on
that the hadith does mean what you say
it means and now you're showing us
verses of the quran
that um we shouldn't be reciting
that's what you're doing that's what
you're doing
and i'll be honest with you that's so
intellectually dishonest
it's i mean that's your opinion but can
i not yeah guess what
right look challenge was
you cannot press on with the premise has
been refuted no
no that's the thing he gave he gave
three reasons why it's allegedly
disputed
so i'm trying to tackle those three
premises right i can't just
tackle them right this is why i asked
you a very simple ray this is why
i asked you a very simple question when
you brought up the quran verse 261
are you trying to demonstrate an example
of a different interpretation of a verse
of the quran is that what you're doing
i'm doing it by his second dimension no
is that what you're doing
is that what you're doing is that what
you are doing
i said yes by his second right right
right
why are you trying to show us different
interpretations of a quranic verse
what do you think different translations
of a quranic verse
what does that demonstrate no no it's
not about the translation it's about ibn
kathir explaining how
foom was ibn abbas's recitation
but what does that demonstrate
what does it demonstrate what it
demonstrates is that there is different
interpretations by his
own meaning that it has to be his own
words
is it the meaning of the word is the
word different is the word
does the word have different um
what does that demonstrate different
if you would let me finish then i would
be able to give my presentation about
why it does represent his question no
what does it demonstrate
it demonstrates that there even at the
time of the sahabah
they
you did exactly what i said you were
doing you were trying to demonstrate an
example in the quran of
the there's differences of opinions and
interpretation
you're trying to use that with the
premise of that hadith again
so you are doing exactly what i said you
would do in me wasting everybody's time
it's a shame it's a shame
johnny or jim or oh you were johnny now
you're changing it to jim
um yeah what's happening
okay
turn your sound up a little bit
or something say again yeah can you hear
me now
yeah much better all right so
i'm an ex-muslim oh wow
yeah so so as you guys said you do want
us to bring some kind of a challenge so
my challenge to you guys is like uh can
you give me some
a good argument that will bring me back
to islam
i've got a brilliant challenge for you
because i say this to every ex-muslim i
meet
you have no intellectual justification
to leave islam
so why did you leave islam
because i didn't find any evidence of
any guard
or i found a lot of scientific errors in
the quran
there's errors in the preservation like
there are questions in the preservation
they are the problem of evil like
there's a lot of other things as well no
give me an intellectual reason you left
islam and
and substantiate it
yeah so like i said like preservation of
quran
all right preservation of the quran so
what was it
about the preservation of the quran that
you rejected
well the fact that a lot of there are
like seven
different variants or you call them
recitations and they have like different
uh like verses are changed the meanings
have changed
so like how can you be sure like it's
like which one is it
is it hubs is it worse rush or like
how how does that affect preservation
it was revealed in those different it
was revealed in seven different um
i don't understand your point so you're
a muslim wait
you're born muslim obviously a muslim
country and then you decide all of a
sudden
that the quran is not preserved based
upon the idea that it was recited in
seven different
ways but that does it would it wouldn't
that wouldn't that make you
go wow not only has it been preserved
it's been preserved in seven different
ways
that should kind of be the opposite of
rejecting preservation
that should be kind of like oh man that
should be rubber stamping preservation
no but the thing is that half the quran
that we read right now
uh it was uh it came like 200 years
after the death of
prophet muhammed so like i'm not sure
like
like what happened between those 200
years like the
quran is like the one that you read
right now right
what's the difference between the hat
score and the quran before it in the 199
years
before yeah that's the question like
what happened to that quran
no no well so what you're saying is
in 199 years afterwards they're in
taraweeh
the readings they're going from sort of
fatiha
then all of a sudden the next year
they're doing something different is
that what you're saying
i'm saying that the 200 years that's
what i'm saying
so 199 years they were reading something
else is your claim
and then on on the 200th year um this
has quran
changes everything so like i said to you
year before tarawih time masha allah
tarawi
okay and what your claim is is in the
year 200
or 200 years the 200 year mark
tarawih changed the quran recitation
changed
so my question to you is what changed
because you're making the claim it's
changed so i want to understand
what changed so like there is
there's like in hatis which tells you
that they were like uh some
surahs were like really long and
some some sugars were eaten by goats and
stuff like that
right you really one second man you go
into the mind wipe gulp yeah
you go into the mind white goat just
just let me ask you a very simple
question so i can understand your
psychology
because what you're doing right now jim
is reinforcing my claim you've got no
intellectual justification for what the
hell you're saying mate but anyway let's
just determine this
so the quran at a uh
piece of paper that had a verse of the
quran written on it
what do you think happened to everyone's
memory
when they go at that
did everyone forget the verse i'm just
saying that that
that is a big question but what happened
no no no no no no
this is intellectual man you you've seen
a hadith where a goat
eats a piece of paper with the verses of
this verse of the quran
apparently okay yeah intellectually
what do you think the ramifications of a
goat in the page
would have had on people who've
memorized
the quran the question is when
this is said by the sahaba that
the verses the sorry the surah was very
long
and now the quotes ate some of the
surahs and we don't see those verses
right right so there's a question one
second
one second jim okay i'm not letting you
off that easy
so the joke the so the so this sort of
was really long that's what you're
saying yeah
and and the goat at part of the surah
is what you're saying is that correct
amount so far yes that's that's one
of these that i'm telling you no this is
this is what this is this is what you're
trying to claim
so the people who'd memorized that surah
what happened to them when the goat at
that piece of paper
yeah so there are other historians which
will tell you that a lot of sahabas who
memorized quran
also died in wars no what happened
in that surah when the people who
memorized this surah
were they in taraweeh and they go at it
and then they've
what they forgot was it like you know i
wish i have i got it
as oh men in black style
my goat might winding goat
i'm sorry mind blocking gold i'm not
saying that this is
how stupid intellectually that sounds
that you think it's like me doing this
right it's like me doing this now
stuff taking a piece of the crap tearing
the page out throwing it up and now no
one knows what the quran said
i'm saying this is a hadith which is
authentic so no
what i'm saying to you is i don't
believe the hadith is authentic anyway
if i'm not wrong but anyway let's just
say it was
how does a goal eat in a page erase
people's memories
i didn't say that i'm saying he did he
did
we forgot what that verse said the
sahabah said that things have changed
the quran is not the same
as it used to be that's what i'm saying
right now um where did this harvest
say so the sahaba said ago in the quran
did war
the sahaba said that the quran used to
be
longer than it is right now it was
it was more detailed and some of the
verses
that gold ate or other reasons there
might be other reasons
but no no no let's stay on the gold
let's say in the gold because you
brought your gold as your star witness
man
that's one of the that that's one of my
claims
the other one right all right i'm gonna
let the other boys deal with you now
mate because i know i understand your
position
um take it away guys
uh jim i i it might sound a little bit
off topic but i'm just
curious were you coming from the sunni
uh
were you coming from a sunni background
or from the shia strand
from the sunni yes okay but so that
you're aware of the suni shia
split right yes okay
the only reason i'm asking this i think
one interesting way that it connects and
maybe this is something uh
maybe this is a angle or a perspective
we don't take as often or that we don't
take as
we don't use as much as we should is
that if you were saying
that the quran was not really
standardized
until 200 years after the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because we don't know what was happening
in that 200 years
firstly you know we do have manuscripts
of the quran that are from
first first century hijri first of all
right
so you can for example go on islamic
awareness
which is a website and you will have
many many manuscripts that are shown
there which are from within the
first century hijri that's number one
right number two is
uh that if the quran was a fluid text
and it was not fixed until around 200
years
after the time of the prophet why are
these changes you are calling them
changes i'm not calling them changes but
these slight variances that exist
between the different kira'at
if these according to you are changes
that were made
or alterations that were made why were
there not any other
major theological alterations or
modifications that were made to the text
of the quran
this is where the sunnisha split
actually helps us i think
it actually helps us because if you have
the uh
if you have uh the the large majority of
muslims who believe that abu bakr
radhiallahu the first khalifa but then
you have another large
sizeable minority that believes that
hazrat ali is entitled to be the first
khalifa
why didn't one of these groups change
the quran
or alter or modify the quran to their
theological advantage
in other words in case i'm not clear
enough uh jim
why didn't why didn't the sunnis insert
some kind of pro-umayyad
bias into the quran why didn't they
insert some kind of pro
abu bakr bias into the quran which the
shia would reject
or vice versa why didn't the shia insert
ali's name into the quran which the
sunnis would reject and now we would
have two completely different versions
of the quran
why didn't any of this happen so the
only way you would be able to explain
that is in order to support your
there's many um conspiracy theories
which can only be supported if you
believe
in even larger supporting uh conspiracy
theories
so your conspiracy theory that the quran
was changed after 200 years
you can only support this if you jump
into even more conspiracy theories now
you have to say
that the battle of cephein never
happened in those first 200 years
of the islamic history you have to say
that the battle of jamal
right that never happened in the first
200 years of islamic history
sunnisha split didn't happen uh the
abbasid revolution
against the umayyads none of that
happened because if you're going to
admit that all of those things happened
i'm asking the question that how is it
that none of these different theological
groups
wanted to alter or change the quran
surely someone would have wanted to have
done that
so to summarize the point is no one was
able to
create an umayyad quran or a shia quran
right or an explicitly sunni quran
because you couldn't play around with
the text of the quran it was a fixed
text it was not a fluid text
as brother hamza alluded to it was a
text that was being recited in its
entirety every ramadan every year
so he had a great question how is it
that in the year you know 199
it was one quran it was okay and in the
year 200 it was suddenly changed
was there a coved worldwide pandemic
where the mosques closed for one year
where muslims are not allowed to go what
happened what does history say so you
have to support your conspiracy theory
with more evidence right i've got a
conspiracy theory that could have
happened
i've got conspiracy theory do you want
to see my conspiracy theory
can i respond to that
that's what happened that mind wiping
goat came again
in the year 199 and he changed
it's just ridiculous
yeah respond respond please do okay sure
thank you
so the point is that the quran that we
read
right now which is the huff's quran it
was standardized in 1924 or something in
egypt
so it's not like i i i it goes in 1924
now
it was standardized in 1924 right right
sorry
because you know what i heard i've heard
this claim i've heard this claim this
1924 claim
now there are people right who had
grandfathers and
fathers so the idea
that somebody's father in the ramadan of
2019-23
was reading something else and then in
24 there was reading something else and
nobody said anything
this is just it's just a madness it's
it's a kind of madness jim to say that
in 1924
when muslims were already i'm sure we
were tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions i'm pretty sure we would have
been hundreds of millions what you're
saying is
that when they changed the quran in 1924
in egypt
all the muslims of indonesia had no
problem with that all of the muslims of
india
the muslims of africa on top of that the
shia muslims the ismaili muslims the
zaidis of yemen they all said
that's fine we'll go along with that no
problem and they didn't raise
any objection about that you tell me jim
you tell me
does that strike you as a reasonable
premise is that a reasonable position to
hold
i'm just telling you what what's like
written in the history
i'm telling you what's what's happened
if you can you can just google it
you can you can search about it even in
saudi arabia
quran was standardized in 1960s or
something
1960s now i think in 1959 they were
reciting something else
no no they were reciting it but it
wasn't standardized
they did it wasn't what were they
reciting what was the difference
they were they were different qurans at
that time as well
that's the point before 1924 he's not
going to do his own tricks does he
does he come like every few hundred
years or something to mind wipe
and start again but jim i'm just asking
you a common sense question which is
that muslims who are ready to debate and
refute one another on all kinds of small
marginal points on small things we
should unfortunately unfortunately we'll
shoot each other down over small things
the size of this guy's beard or the way
this guy folds his hands when he prays
but when it came to our central text
when it came to our
central scripture our holy scripture uh
we allowed saudi arabia to change that
sometime in the 1960s
and there was no uh there was no
disapproval from the muslim world
there was no disapproval uh from from
the other sunni muslims
or from the shia muslims saying hey
saudi arabia is changing the quran
i just want to understand your mindset i
want to understand where people are
coming from
how is it that muslims who are ready to
dispute and fight
and refute one another on all kinds of
small marginal issues
on this most central important point
they laid down their arms and they said
hey you know what
unity is more important go ahead and
change the quran
unity is more important my brother i'm
not going to condemn you for doing it
does it i mean does it really make sense
to you jim i think that we should i'm
not saying that they changed it i'm not
saying that they changed
i'm saying that the first uh version of
quran was already there
but they just standardized it what do
you mean by standards what do you mean
by standardized then what's
what's the problem then if they didn't
change it
well this this practice has been going
on for quite some time quran has been
burned uh by abu bakr as well and
we all know that so so
i'm going to say it to you as well mate
you're waffling
you're waffling and um
thank you for coming on and
demonstrating
there is no intellectual justification
for me come on
tell us the real reason you left islam
tell us the real reason
it's got nothing to do with preservation
jim let's be honest let's be honest come
on cards on the table here
there is no way you left islam because
you didn't think the preservation was
there
we both know that's not true left islam
well the other other big reason was the
problem of evil no i want the real
reason
why you left this of evil is not why you
left islam either
why did you leave islam that's that's a
big problem what was her name
sorry what why did you leave islam
problem of evil is not the reason you
left islam
and we both know that why why are you
lying to yourself what was the reason
you left
islam what was the reason
i'm telling you problem
if it's the problem of evil how old were
you when you left islam
i was 25 25 and prior to the day before
you left islam
were you praying five times a day and
all that
no no how long before leaving islam had
you stopped praying
uh 23 i guess so two years prior you
stopped praying
so let's be honest was you practicing
islam at the time
were you fasting yeah yes i was fasting
and i used to go to
moss like on fridays or something i
wasn't a good muslim at that time
but uh so i became a doubter i became a
skeptic and slowly
uh i read quran and everything people
are people are telling us in the
comments to test them you know
the surah fatiha test
that's not the point the point is this
everybody here knows
he did not leave islam because of the
problem of evil
he's using that as a justification to
leave islam his reasons for leaving
islam
have got nothing to do with intellect
nothing is to do with nuts and desires
and whims
whether or not you suffered abuse at the
hands of muslims i don't know
whether your imam should twist your ear
i don't know
yeah whether you're forced to marry
someone you didn't want to marry i don't
know
what i can tell by your excuses
what your excuses are nothing more than
that i don't you reach it for jay smith
for some reason
it's like subhanallah these are your
trying
these are your attempts to justify your
emotional reason for leaving
islam and i think we all know that and i
don't know why you're afraid just to
stay
just tell us why you left this now i'm
being very honest to you
i would love to join back
my issue then i just wanna i wanna
advise that why is that because
my whole family is muslim so i'm like
the odd one out i'll be i'll be happy to
join islam anytime
but i just don't find a good reason to
do so that's why i'm here maybe you can
give me a good reason
so let's talk about the problem of evil
because that's the one that i'm most
interested in is first off i want to
understand what you
understand about the problem why is it a
problem to you that's something i want
to know before we go on
further yeah so like we know that god
god is all good
right and if god is so good then how is
he allowing
like let's say rape for example of a
three-year-old girl
and stuff like that like murders of like
innocent children and stuff like that
like it doesn't make sense to me like if
god is all
good then all good god shouldn't be
allowing this
why not yeah because
if someone is all good then then there
is no place for allowing evil
because only an evil person will allow
that
no an evil person will only allow it if
they can't do anything about it
or they choose not to do something about
it
yes so if so for example if i if i have
the power
to rectify whatever happens why is it
that i have to stop it in the moment
sorry can you repeat that so for example
let's say that i have the power to do
whatever i want right
i have the power to control reality as
we know it
right and an evil occurs in my presence
but i know for a fact that at the end of
the day
or judgment day as it is right i can
just
reverse everything i can reward uh for
all the pain and suffering that somebody
is given i can rectify everything to
such an extent that that evil becomes
meaningless
in my eyes in my capacity not the
capacity of the individual
even well actually in the capacity
individual as well i can change their
perception of everything right
so that no longer becomes an evil but
becomes a means for reward for them
so how is it that i'm evil now because
like say like somebody got raped
okay now as a response to that rape not
only do i punish the person
in hell fire but i also make sure that
that person who is raped
gets such a reward that now what they
went through
no longer means anything to them that
they are so grateful
for everything that i've done how am i
still evil
that's what i'm trying to do yes so like
because you still allowed it
if if it's such a tiny thing it doesn't
matter
then why would you even do that why
would you even allow something like that
why didn't you just move heaven to the
person
and uh if you already know that that's
gonna happen then why would you wait for
it to happen okay well now we're talking
about pre-determined now we're talking
about knowledge of the future
but what i'm trying to ask you is how is
it that i'm evil
because you asked you answered me with a
question so i'm asking you how is it
that i'm still
evil if i can rectify everything
now you say a person is somebody who
allows it but i'm so i'm offering you
another thing it's like i can rectify
whatever occurs to the point where that
evil is no longer even perceived as such
by the individual who was affected yeah
but
but the thing is that the game that
you're playing makes you the evil
character in this case
because because you allowed it even if
you can rectify it it doesn't
it doesn't give you the authority to do
that because
if you're all good then you shouldn't
allow it why shouldn't i allow it if i'm
all good you're simply repeating what
you said earlier
yeah because because that's the point
right okay so if i want to give a child
a vaccine
there's going to be some pain involved
with the shot right
should i not allow that to occur
despite the benefit that they'll gain in
the process
well if you could avoid the pain then
you would right
it depends sometimes it doesn't matter
well it doesn't matter but that rape
does matter because if rape is because
it does matter yeah it doesn't matter
but i'm talking i tried to give you an
analogy that was much less significant
but now we're talking about somebody
we're talking about a god we're talking
about somebody with
all-powerful all-knowing can do
whatever he wants right and can reward
people for even the slightest prick of
their finger
to such an extent where it's like they
don't even we have hadith on this as
well where people
will will look back on their lives and
all the evil that was done to them and
because of the reward that allah has
given them
they will say i didn't even suffer at
all that's literally
part of our religion yeah so then what's
the point of giving the suffering
okay there's a difference between saying
what's the point of it and there's
something then saying that that god is
evil as a result
so are you admitting to the possibility
that god could possibly not be evil if
he's able to rectify to such an extent
with that evil is no longer perceived as
such well that
i keep repeating it because like if i do
something bad to you
but then i rectify it and then give you
a million dollars that still doesn't
discount what i did to you right
even if i give you a billion dollars
afterwards and you'll be like okay thank
you
my life is good you did to me you're
rectified but you've messed up now
because
it's not about like like us not saying
you're saying now if you did something
to somebody and
you're acting like god did this to them
god determined this for them
yeah god allowed it no no that's not
great you know allowing something to
happen is very different from actually
doing it to person
um committing an adjustment if a person
stands next to a girl getting raped
and doesn't do anything then i'll be
we'll be charging him with
you know something but god does
something about it eventually
won't if if a person is not
doing anything just watching a person
getting raped yeah you're charging them
with what
you mean what what crime will you charge
them with
you may not charge them with any kind
but you you know what i'm saying that
he's not only no you just said you
charged him
to do something yeah right something if
he had if he's holding a sniper
and he doesn't shoot the rapist then
then he is part of it so so you're
saying so he hasn't killed the guy
he's part of the rape
that's in the context of the limitation
of the individual himself because we
would require ourselves to do something
about it right because we have no power
to do anything after the fact
right but god doesn't he doesn't have
that limitation he can literally like if
you die in a fire
he can literally reverse it and give you
your skin back and and give you the
perception that it never even happened
like so why does he have to in the
moment he has to rescue you from the
fire
like what what is stopping him from why
does he need to do like someone trying
to figure out why does he need to do
this
to not be perceived as evil because
because the attribute of fame is he's
all good
yes and part of being all good is he's
able to rectify
and cause that evil to no longer so
you're saying that is an elephant in the
room
here this term all good does allah say
he's all good
yes he like in aramaic raheem it's all
said no no no no it's besides the point
okay no i'll just keep hearing this all
good like christians
let everybody else go i just want to
finish off my point really quickly here
yeah you're going to start continuing
is that the problem of evil is not a
problem for god because god
for evil and good in terms of how we
perceive things
it doesn't it's like it doesn't even
exist for him because everything that we
complain about
he can rectify in an instance right so
when you say well he allows this to
happen
we can question we can ask okay what's
the point of that but then to
automatically come to the conclusion
that he's evil while still trying to ask
what the point is doesn't make much
sense to me
either there is a point that makes that
actually makes him immune from this
criticism
which you have alluded to the
possibility of which i want to discuss
or there isn't so which one is it
yeah so i'm just saying that if what
you're saying is this
that he can rectify it so therefore
he will remain all good but my point is
that if
in some point of time he becomes evil
or he allows evil and then he rectifies
it
and he's all good again that still
doesn't discount the fact that he was
evil once
but that's a strong man because i never
claimed that he could become evil and
good now he's always good
because if the point of the suffering is
ultimately
a good in his perception in his eyes and
his
construction of the universe yeah but
then why is it
but you would say that rape is evil
right yes i would say rape is evil yes
of course
yes so he is allowing that evil thing to
happen right so he's
that by that definition he's not all
good right
no even if he rectifies it after some
time
let's suppose i can give you an example
of me like for example i give you a drug
or something and i do something to you
in the morning you don't remember
anything
so it's like it never happened to you
but i'm still the evil guy here right
yes because you are the one who
performed the evil
yes but if if someone allowed it let's
say
if someone saw me doing it and didn't do
anything if someone had the power to do
it
okay so somebody hasn't saw this doctor
so he goes so he sees that i have been
drugged
and he kills that person and then spares
me
okay what is the difference between
allah eventually sending somebody to
hell
and then rectifying the pain and
suffering that that person went through
because allah that time doesn't do
anything and you just watch it
why does he have to do it at that time
that's one point that i'm trying to make
because he's really good because he has
the power to do so yes he does he also
has the power to
act to to create is such an event where
that
event didn't even actually have any
significance whatsoever
thereby removing the criticism towards
him
that why did he allow it to happen when
the thing that he allowed to happen no
longer has significance
jim what if you had to if you had to
choose if you had to choose what would
you prefer
to to keep and to maintain your free
will
or guaranteed safety on the other hand
so guaranteed personal security and
safety or free will if you had to if you
had to choose between
one of these two things what would you
choose
i think that's a difficult question um
well it depends what do you mean by
safety
well if i said that you can move to a
society right now where you're basically
a slave
you're you're a complete slave of the
state but guaranteed you will not be
affected by crime you will not be
murdered you will not be raped
so in that sense your your personal
security and safety is guaranteed
versus living in what we call a free
society right
where you you know you are free to go
and do the activities that you please
but you you
run a risk of of uh of of of personal
injury
of being affected by street crime
what would you pro i know what the
majority of people would prefer what
they would say but what would you prefer
be real i would prefer free will yes
right so then we're complaining about
something that we shouldn't be
complaining about right because don't
you think don't don't don't you think
that that what we call evil is basically
a byproduct of free will
if god gives us free will to choose
between good and bad
and he gives us the freedom to make
mistakes
uh which often times non-muslims like
yourself
like to sometimes even boast about that
i let my children make their own
decisions
i let my daughter i love myself i let
them make their own decisions let them
make their own mistakes they have to be
responsible they have to learn
right that that's that's a virtue so uh
then we shouldn't be complaining about
free will in the first place don't you
think evil is a byproduct of free will
if we're going to allow people to choose
between good and bad that choice is only
meaningful
right if god doesn't supernaturally
intervene every time i make an evil
decision in my life
in other words every time i decide to do
something evil like steal some money
from your pocket
god has to you know send down a
thunderbolt at that very moment he has
to work according to your watch
and he has to prevent that theft from
taking place then my evil choice is
meaningless it's not even evil anymore
in a world where i know i'm going to be
stopped and prevented from doing
anything evil
harming anybody that even that choice is
meaningless so my point is for
free will to be meaningful there has to
be
risk there has to be harm there has to
some amount of suffering in a world in
which free will
is is is a real thing it's a meaningful
thing
does that make any sense at all to you
uh but i can then question like
why do you need to have evil like why
can't you just have free will and not
have evil because that would be free
what would it be
i got a controversial question for you
mate that's what i'm trying to explain
that's what i'm trying to explain i i
can only conceive of that
kind of free will not being free will at
all that that kind of free will would be
meaningless you know
um like like that would be like me
telling my son hey look i give you all
the freedoms you want okay
uh you can make whatever choice you want
and the second he's
he steps out of the door at 11 p.m at
night to go to a nightclub i
grab him and i shackle him to the bed
and i say no you're not so what what
kind of
freedom did i really give him in that
situation right so again for free will
to be meaningful
suffering as well as what we call evil
is a necessary byproduct of that i mean
this is how i
conceive of it this is how i am right
i've got a controversial question for
you jim why is rape evil
on an on uh atheistic worldview
yeah it's because it creates pain and
suffering why is that evil
i don't believe that anything is like
inherently evil
oh okay well that stops there a
consistent atheist yeah
i'm troubled by the fact if we only
define something evil as something which
incurs
suffering or pain i i find that
definition to be very insufficient so
for example
if i were to modify if i were to
carry one point just one point jim if i
were to modify your earlier example
and say that like a man drugs a woman
right
and then he sleeps with her without her
consent he doesn't cause her pain he
doesn't cause her suffering right
he wears a condom he has he uses
contraception he drugs her and he sleeps
with her without her consent
the next day she wakes up and she's fine
and she goes about living her life she's
not pregnant she's not harmed
so but by your definition which i find
to be inadequate
insufficient if pain and suffering is
only the only
criterion by which you judge something
to be evil how how is that
how is that uh act evil according to
your atheistic worldview
okay but before i before answer that
question i just like to say
when i say that there is nothing
inherently evil
which i mean the word evil as we use it
is like religious right but why is
hurting people
just i know you're going to say that's
that gentleman why is great people i
want to understand
why even if you hurt suffer them in your
world view why is evil
yeah i just told you it causes pain and
suffering you're not getting
why is causing pain and suffering evil
you cannot function in society like that
why not
you know you know jim that that is one
way of escaping the problem of evil you
know adopting a world view in which
nothing is evil nothing is
problem solving well your atheistic
world view who cares if he calls
suffering and pain
so what if you're benefiting from it
what's the problem
why should someone suffer this problem
of evil is not a problem for me
because i i know okay okay so
we understand we understand what you're
saying what you're saying is
under your world view uh there is no
inherent evil
therefore you're not making a positive
argument you're simply saying
within the islamic view there is an
incoherency because we believe in all
loving god but evil exists is that what
you're saying yes
okay good now that would basically go
against something that you previously
stated
which is this is a problem for you it's
not a problem for you
now you've changed your stance
said this is a problem for islam like no
no no
no no no you said you said earlier this
is a problem for you
yes when i was a muslim no so now you're
not a muslim
you don't know now you're not a muslim
it's not a problem for you that rape
killing pillaging genocide like what the
chinese communist party is doing
none of these things bother you as being
in
inherently evil they are just as random
as the particles moving around in a test
tube
for you oh this is a problem i didn't
say this is not a problem i said
the problem of evil itself
as a concept is we agree do we agree
that there is no problem of evil for you
there's no such thing for you as an
atheist
sorry there is bad things that are bad i
know
that things that can cause you pain and
suffering and we should avoid those
things
rape is bad therefore we should avoid
yeah but you've changed your position
again
you've changed your position again you
said there was no inherent evil and now
you're saying there is evil
what is it which one is it decide yeah
that's what i said
i don't want to use the word evil
because as an atheist which i
am right now there is no like because
evil the word evil is religious in
nature right so i don't use the
no it's not no it's not again look
you're changing your position
and you're firing blank shots yeah you
just said it's a religious term evil's a
religious term no it's not
evil's not religious term where did you
get that from
brother sabor even if he was right i
don't think he's endearing himself
to the audience because then he's he's
he's admitting that without religion
you know there is no evil this is not
making your
your worldview look any more attractive
or or
that same rate would still take place
but there'll be no justice
as adults there is that there is that
but there's also something else to keep
in mind right
atheists come across as super
empathetic oh my god there's even the
world i can't believe this
and oh by the way i don't really believe
in evil well
you you can't be that i'm sorry you
can't be that melodramatic about evil in
the world and suffering
and that impassioned thing you spoke
about earlier about rape and then just
as a side comment say there's no
intrinsic evil
we're not going to let that slide that
makes it or conveniently
or conveniently label religion as evil
evil religion is the one exception to
the rule you know there is no evil
because evil is is associated with the
devil and all those things so that's why
you wanted to use the word evil but okay
you're an atheist you're an atheist he's
raping somebody evil
by your definition yes it would be no no
by your understanding
according to you
evil jim is raping somebody evil do you
know what
i'm sorry i'm i'm so sorry uh
whatever your name is uh you've got jim
and you've got picked off
some some other guy um you just made
a point that's gonna be a meme right now
right you just
mean to yourself you're gonna be on the
internet for a long time
so basically what you just pointed out
is why
people should actually be muslim because
if you want to say rape is wrong
then you gotta have some sort of
theistic worldview thank you very much
for that
and the thing is even if we change the
word evil to objectively wrong
okay objectively wrong yes i i i still
don't think you'll be able to
to talk your way out of it uh like you
know why is rape
objectively wrong or the scenario with
that idea
for that scenario of the the woman
that's been drugged she didn't have any
pain
and he gives you the condom and that so
there's no pain or suffering
why is that act evil because society
cannot work like that
what does that mean why would society
why not
wait one second jim jim i don't know i'm
pretty sure that's not your name
why the hell society working together is
some absolute
maximum perfect position that is the
standard for right and wrong stat
society working or society not working
is as indifferent you should be as
indifferent to that as you are
to particles floating around in a test
tube
let's see you're piggybacking on
religion without knowing it because that
also
causes a problem for your argument
because if you're talking about society
functioning if we're going to use the
pragmatic argument of society's
functioning
okay civilization overall let's look at
history because
there has never been an atheist
anti-supernatural civilization ever
and there's a reason for that because
those societies don't function
and the last time that we saw them
actually come into fruition
was during the 20th century when they
basically slaughtered half their
populations
and then crumbled from within and i can
name a couple of names
so my point that i'm trying to make is
you want to make that point about you
know
society functioning as a measure
of goodness or morality then you've
basically given
your hand to religious belief systems
because those are the only societies
that have ever existed
and ever will exist in human history
uh we don't have there is no historical
success story
of an atheistic anti-supernatural
civilization on this planet and there
never will be
i'm just being honored to do that so
yeah that's a great point so jim
irrespective of whether you're convinced
of the theology of islam or not
of the preservation of the quran or not
just for social functional pragmatic
reasons you should become a muslim you
asked us
for reasons for why you should be a
muslim be a muslim because you'll be a
better father
be a muslim because you'll be a better
husband be a muslim because
a religious devout muslim is less likely
to cheat on his spouse you'll be helping
society right
not the ideal reason to be muslim but
you you ask for a reason
that's one the other reason is jim if if
you are truthful and i'm going to assume
that you are
you are a muslim you are coming from a
muslim background you were once
practicing this practicing islam you
said give us a reason for why you should
come back
i would say ask yourself ask within
yourself
what that reason could be why is it that
you're looking for a reason to come back
what is that brought you onto a muslim
live stream what is it that you're
missing about islam
because i know you're missing something
right on a psychological level on an
emotional level there's something that
you're missing
otherwise you wouldn't come back and say
hey give me a reason
i want to believe so i would ask you to
pose that question to yourself
what is it that islam was giving you
that your current worldview is not able
to give you
what is it that islam was providing for
you in your life
that your current worldview and society
is not able to provide for you
ask this question within yourself my
brother
okay sure thank you yeah i'll just drop
off thanks guys
i i i think i think you should and
i think
to be honest with you all the answers
masha allah is a brilliant forget
jim and his flex this is a common
question about people
like evil and this and that and you guys
man you just smashed it
i know i think it's i didn't understand
where he was trying to
assert i mean one of the things that i
think the big problem is that atheists
always like to
conflate human uh
responses or human perceptions
perceptions of
evil actions with god like as though we
have the same abilities we have the same
functions we have the same everything
like you know well if you
did this or you you know then it would
be evil it's like well i'm not
god okay and if i had god's power
you know i would probably have a very
different response to certain things
depending on how much i know and what i
can do
right like yeah if i see a woman being
raped i'm going to jump in and try to do
something
because i have no other ability
otherwise i mean i have to do something
you know like either i do something in
that moment or that woman gets raped
right and this is something within my
small perspective of things right
so of course yeah i'm obligated as a
human being to be
as a moral person to do something but
god it's like
not only does he know whether
everything's going on but like literally
what he's seeing around him like this is
this is not
something he can't deal with not
something that he can't resolve
he doesn't have to do it in the moment
you know and that may cause some people
to be like
kind of go back and go well you know
that doesn't make me feel comfortable
well it's like
you need to look at the grand scheme of
things we're talking about
in existence that will eventually this
small existence that we have here
is a very small part of our existence
right eventually we're going to be an
eternity in one of two places
if you look at it from that perspective
you know
are you does it is it really that cringe
worthy to think about it from the
perspective of an omnipotent
being
i got two points just to make very
quickly and i like the example of the
vaccine
now a baby's one thing but if you went
to a five-year-old
you came with this big needle and you
stuck it in their arm
they're gonna think you're evil that
person is evil
they've hurt me but they can't
comprehend and i think that's one thing
is about the comprehension
the other thing is this the idea that
anything because bad things happen in
the world
this being god doesn't exist now the way
i look at it
is well what if god wants and wants to
allow bad things to happen in the world
based upon people's choices
then that's evidence for god existing
so the the idea that because
you just because he and this is why i
tried to address it earlier
this all good business i don't believe
as much as we hold this position
we're not we're not god is love god is
aziz
god is all powerful god is our idol god
is a judge the gods can put people in
hell fire
god doesn't love rapists and pedophiles
and murderers
the idea this all love all loving
allah loves his creation but he's give
them free will and he doesn't love those
who do
the bad things yeah that's a good point
and
and like you were i think as you were
alluding to earlier i mean if
if anything evil can testify to the
existence of a creator
because if the if there is objective
evil which atheists aren't very sure
about
then there must be objective good as
well too and what is that measure what
is that objective measure of objective
good
they don't have an answer to that we
have an answer to that right yeah
and to brother asadula's point
absolutely i mean i heard a
beautiful analogy once an example which
is that think of all the crazy you know
hair raising
nightmares that we've had in our
lifetime right i mean i've had nightmare
nightmares where like a bear is chasing
me and he's ripped off my arm and
there's blood gushing out of the
arm right and when you wake up you know
five seconds later you're not bothered
by it at all you know you
you don't you're you're you're happy and
you're thankful and you're grateful and
it's over right so
that's how we approach it that's how
believers optimistically
uh approach it the other thing is i i
really do think a lot of atheists who
are stuck on this problem of evil thing
aside from the whole inconsistency of it
i think they've really
underrated the importance of free will
or they've misunderstood what
what free will is you know and if god
did everything that they
expect or they claim they want god to do
then they would call him a dictator or a
tyrant
because think of the secular equivalent
think of the worldly equivalent if
if our governments came out with a plan
and said hey we can instill this
microchip in every citizen in the
country
and once you have this microchip
instilled you won't have any bad
thoughts you'll never even you'll never
be tempted to steal
you'll never be tempted to rape you'll
never be tempted to fornicate
you won't want to do drugs any longer
how many of these atheists are going to
line up for that microchip
they're going to say that's taking away
our agency
that's taking away our free will so if
you want to champion free will and
agency then i the way i understand it
the natural byproduct of that is a world
in which things are going to be
imperfect because people are going to
make imperfect choices and decisions
there is a movie actually that people
want to experience
what it's like um is the movie minority
report
where people are arrested
before they can commit the crime they're
intending to do
so they haven't done anything but
because they were going to do that thing
they were arrested and
i'm just thinking about them they were
thinking about it yeah yeah because they
were thinking
no because they were going they were
thinking about doing it yeah and i think
they were going to go through with it if
i'm not wrong if i remember the movie
me because there was those crazy it was
just like it was just like them having a
thought about it
yeah or was it just a thought about us
like if you planned something yeah
obviously in the end he he and the
amazon spoiler in the end
he himself who's the arresting company
so everybody if you want to witness a
world
that's what that is referring to i'm not
going to say the answer i'm going to go
spoilers
but everybody wants to witness a world
where
your your very thoughts of doing
something wrong
are corrected before you do that wrong
watch minority report yeah and that
speaks to my point too hamza which is
that if
god did what they claim they want god to
do then they would call him a tyrant or
a dictator
so the next time an atheist says well
why did my
cousin die of cancer if i were to tell
him well because allah knew he was going
to murder somebody that's why he took
his life
try selling that to an atheist they
won't buy that that's not gonna
satisfy anybody they do the same thing
with comprehension too if you notice
this when it comes to the quran well why
can't the quran be clear to everyone and
and just tell everyone what it says and
like there can't be no misinterpretation
whatsoever like there's no blame to be
on the person whatsoever like
allah has to come down and like
literally force the interpretation into
every human being
because you know we can't take
responsibility for our own ignorance our
own inability to do certain things
it's like they want the same thing and
it's always funny because they're like
we're free thinkers
except we want a lot of forces to think
yeah it's tom cruise not the christian
bale by the way it's a tom cruise movie
yeah just so you know someone in the
chat saying christian bale
is christian bailey i don't think so
all right um i'm be honest i'm looking
at the the back chat hassan al-bukhari
um
ray now ray's toes
and then we got imam nissan mohammed and
his real name is matty proponent
get out of here all right um
you want to give him the last shot
um why so religious uh yeah
oh you're ray aren't you forgot
do you know why we call him ray because
we came on because he was like behaving
like a wise guy
and then because he was white so
religious and then we said oh rayleigh
otter and then we gotta call him ray
so he calls himself reno
all right let's give hasanah bukhari a
shot i think he's a muslim though you're
muslim bro
i'm pretty sure he's a muslim yeah
first of all my english is not that well
so
if you think i am like uh not delivering
the message
just to kick me out uh
i'll just ask you to clarify okay
uh so i'm going to read the arabic
telephone
so what the hadith actually emphasize on
is the a closeness of your hearts
so if you read the quran with the group
of
muslims okay and you are discussing the
interpretation
um and this interpretation actually
uh is making your hearts to come close
together you know
uh but if you dispute
if you dispute and that dispute
gonna cause uh an illness in your hearts
towards each other
you it's like you're gonna have
something in you in your heart
against each other so stop leave it
okay i can go to the other room and
discuss the same verse or recite it with
my brother
that even i'm gonna dispute with him but
if that is not going to
cause an illness in our hearts towards
each other uh that
i can't do that but with that person
that
even it's gonna cause dispute but
we are not gonna hate each other i can
still
recite it you understand yeah
you could even uh you could even go a
step further and say all right you're
with
sam with sadat and we disagree on an
interpretation of a verse
okay agree with that verse
so i could go and recycle with us um and
obviously that we might argue about the
interpretation but with azure
we're both together so the idea what
what what basically
um ray was trying to say is that because
me and
me and sadat don't agree in that verse i
can't even read it with asadullah
i just have to can't i can't read that
verse of the quran yeah you
you're even carrying which would then be
which would then mean i would have
ascertained everyone's understanding of
that interpretation of that verse of the
quran
now i'm pretty sure most people agree
with me when you pray your salah
you you don't really know what sure
you're going to go with
depending how you feel exactly you
actually said the same
thing that i said when you give that
example yeah and you
actually you can still recite it with or
and discuss it with
sadat if that doesn't cause enmity
yeah yes exactly that's and this is what
the language implies and uh
our understanding of the uh
of that of islam as a whole it fits
the language the exercises of the salaf
and our view of islam so
this is what and it's emphasized on the
a closeness of your of their believers
hearts
so if the dispute gonna cause
the opposite this is when it's applied
in this context because it's this is
the key word here the closeness of your
heart
so yeah this kind of
sorry this kind of then brings us point
into it as well where it's talking about
together
yeah i mean that is reciting it
reciting it and also discussing it
interpreting it yeah i mean this this i
mean it
that strikes me as very you know
reasonable and even
common sense this is almost common sense
that if we're having a discussion
and now brother hamza and i start
getting into a really heated argument
about it about any discussion right not
just the quran
it's it's common sense and it's it's
wise to say okay you know what man let's
just
let it rest let's just put it to the
side for the time being
let's move on right but what is not
reasonable yeah what is not reasonable
is what that gentleman was saying is
that the the meaning of that
the meaning of that hadith is that
indefinitely you can never
recite that quran in a public setting
you can't recite it in a mosque
you can't recite it in tarawih anymore
ever right
no one ever had that interpretation and
that's written's interpretation
yeah yeah exactly because he's upset
about french
french muslims blocking the roads ring
ring in the street
yeah yeah my brother
that was beautiful man that that just
closed that topic down like
beautiful all right guys i think we'll
call it a time martial
it's been nearly three hours jazakallahu
for everybody joining martial i should
be using unfortunately he didn't get to
join i don't know
what happened uh okay he's taking care
of his mom alhamdulillah no problem
whatsoever
all right guys so i'm gonna say salaam
alaikum to everybody
and um did you anything anyone got
anything more to say with regards
anything coming up what you're doing
let's promote you guys obviously so that
the canadian brother
bro you were like on fire
today man you were like that's why i
need
that's why i need six month breaks after
this subhanallah
you were on on it today subhanallah i
just want to
close out by saying
that's right but you know what i thought
was really impressive about today to be
honest with you
most of the guests were complete crap
complete garbage stupid nonsense
arguments and what we demonstrated here
today
was we don't care about you and your
ego and your um intentions
we're just going to use your stupid
argument and we're going to teach the
people
and we're going to teach the muslims and
the non-muslims some beautiful things
about islam
and also at the same time collapse your
world views because atheists now
forget about the problem of evil because
you don't even care
that's the reality because you have no
moral anchor
you have nothing to measure evil against
so i i know i'll say it again why is
hurting people a bad thing
well because they suffer why is that a
bad thing is
isn't it does it matter in the great
scheme of things
when there is no scheme of things this
is just the moment
all right all right i'm going to say
we'll see you in a moment's time brother
i'm sorry i couldn't bring you any uh
intellectual atheist man to get your
teeth in
oh that's fine that's fine um though so
it was good yeah i i did want to add
something
uh here um
when we look at militantly atheistic
uh countries right and i'm using that
term
uh the way it is uh the way i did for a
reason
militantly atheistic countries uh who
want to evangelize such as the chinese
communist party who's uh
who against who we did a protest
yesterday here in london
you find you will not have anybody
who will carry out evil actions
against innocent people to the level
that the atheist governments do
in the entire history of the world so if
you have a taoist government a deistic
uh government um you know
a government which is muslim or
christian or
whatever you anybody with faith anybody
with the belief
in a moral code which is unchangeable
will never do
to the level of evil that these
communist
atheist type of states do and even if
the state's not communist they're just
atheistic states
and one of the reason for that is
because
when you deny god's existence then you
have a type of hypocrisy now that
uh guy who joined us earlier did you
notice how he was so emotional about
oh you know what if a woman is raped and
why isn't god getting involved like he
used this such
but then when it came down to his own
belief he's like well i don't believe
anything to be intrinsically evil
and that fundamental contradiction leads
to genocides that fundamental
contradiction leads to oppression that
fundamental
contradiction leads to mass rape
internment separation of mothers from
their children
people having their fingernails pulled
out and all sorts of things which these
atheistic
militantly atheistic societies do so
even though in the arena
we're here to challenge like head-on
islamophobes and militant atheists and
militant christians this isn't just for
average people to enter it's a
gladiators type of arena
what we have to understand is that
there's real life implications
of these pernicious beliefs that these
people hold
which is why we need to smash it out of
the park um
you know these types of beliefs we don't
just gently deal with them we literally
have to
extract them and show how incredibly
stupid they are
so that normal people get killed
somehow beautifully i have so many
people saying to me why do muslims care
why do you want to speak to everyone
leave everyone to believe well you can't
you just can't you know personally we're
not selfish we want to give everyone
the fantastic way of life which is islam
but when people
left their own devices become their own
gods anything's on the agenda as long as
they get away with it
and these like you said these atheistic
governments they've got no
accountability in their mind they've got
the power they do what they like
no one can do anything alhamdulillah
mr man honestly i need i need to try and
tie you down once a month can you do
once a month
just one friday a month yeah
you you need to like get some
[Music]
get
look i'll be honest with you i mean this
is no lie honestly support right
we rinse everybody in the arena
[Laughter]
nobody's walked out the arena like with
their belief or their claim or their
concept intact
nobody and so what happens if people are
afraid because
their world view is going to get wrecked
when they come in here so i have to
actually go on tick-tock looking for
people
to try and bring them in because they're
kind of naive they're
they're they're not aware of what's
going on do you get me they're still you
know
i like to say they're in the 1980s
they're still coming with alas and moon
god and all that kind of stuff so it's
like yeah
i always say to them come to the arena
and say that please
because you know alhamdulillah we look
forward to that anyway my brother
insha'allah salaam alaikum keep up the
good work insha'allah
salaam alaikum
and that's it another arena another
friday over um for everybody in the chat
i
i don't go on about this but i don't
even check the likes man or mr member i
missed a member sorry sorry sorry sorry
i know i don't need to do the members
but over there but there we go
pepe guess masha allah welcome to the
pride
and uh this is for you very quickly
clear as well
enjoy that i enjoyed that i i thought
subhanallah the um
the things learned today i'm i'm gonna
have to get
i'm gonna have to clip that evil part
because that was just
rinsed rinsed drinks rinsed without
messing around and even the reflex i
need to clip that and then add that
brother masha allah buhari
hasn't put it together because it was
just
knockout alejandra 1 200 likes okay
we'll deal with that we'll deal with
that alhamdulillah
um it wasn't the perfect storm it was
this is
uh this is the arena this is this is um
this is where i'm kind of a little bit
more off the out the cage should i say
than um
than in ef tower and stuff um
this was my sentiment guests were awful
but the res we we used them
to go such beautiful responses man
oh there were such beautiful responses
are you doing neil i know you were dying
to get on man do you want to want to
come on and just say something i don't
mind because it's been a while
and i'm assuming you're not driving your
truck
you haven't changed friday night's
livestream title yet i know
forget friday nights did you see the
live stream today and the live stream
um yesterday
the cheeky live literally cheeky night
there was a lot of things going on about
cheeks
uh though martial our brother shibuya
was
he got stuck taking care of his mother
mashallah because she's not well and
he's taking care of her so alhamdulillah
the next stream for us is
open forum i open forum tomorrow on ef
tower on
sunday ef tower uh you saw me
i know i know i know i know obviously
i've not even looked back at that yet
you know that
yeah yeah yeah yeah because we had a guy
who left
islam because he was gay all right and
um
we had some um serious um
discussion on that
uh
we need woody to enter the stream now
woody adds in the comment section
woody's afraid which is fair enough we
don't mind
i think i have to change that title i
already did that so people would see it
uh yeah the mask police
i thought they were gonna do me but they
didn't i was shocked um
i didn't keep it going i didn't go for
five hours today so alhamdulillah
um
when was what of what happened
um young girls young worlds never learns
he is going to give us
what can we do oh i have to share this
comment your channel on jordann's
channel are my two favorite on youtube i
get to laugh i get to learn more about
my dean i get to read from amazing
brothers
and amazing sisters masha allah and
that's what it's all about that's what
i'm trying to build at my channel here
is the family man alhamdulillah i i love
seeing you guys interacting recognizing
and it's fantastic but i don't have to
be here and you guys are just chatting
so this is what i love about my channel
and this is one of the reasons i did it
to give it that personal touch and
uh mashallah um he wasn't
he was ex-muslim that was his
intellectual justification
uh
what do you think about pine creek is he
keeps attacking islam the dogs are
barking but the caravan is moving on
i think warm as a pacing up to match the
time span of the arena yeah today's
warm-up was really cool i enjoyed it i
enjoyed it i got that tick-tock question
on
what are you saying all right i'm gonna
now i'm gonna
i'll just i'll just keep chatting and
chatting and chatting all right guys so
um what's next sunday
sunday live come check us out 11 until
one o'clock i just shoot the breeze like
this
um comment section drives the show so we
talk about whatever you're talking about
and so that's a good one um
why do you make a group that we can also
learn this is all right
in the words of madness
waiting for a day that never comes
uh
uh hamza's then i got the clear quran
today from ayaz at ef tower i appreciate
very much i'm on the right path
inshallah
insha allah my brother inshallah next
arena is in two weeks time
um guests will be back to our use of
ponders masha'allah
um sheikh man will be back in the
house and i haven't decided the next two
guests at the moment
i might invite um
i might invite ali dawa or benikrah into
the next one insha allah
[Music]
why is that stealing you see it's a
deeper question than that
um who cares
why why is causing pain and suffering
evil
that's my question you're an atheist
so what if someone's in pain and
someone's suffering why should you care
what should make you care
what what is the standard
when will you see me next all right
you'll see me next sunday live
11th one and then inshallah be on e f
tower
and we are open forum i believe it's
open for i think it's open forum
um and that's that inshallah
um yeah i'm gonna go i'm i'm waffling
now
yeah i know you're not letting me leave
because he's reading your bloody
comments it's my fault
uh yeah daniel that's the one guy
i think i am going to try and get
because people kept saying to me
and i'm thinking i don't really know him
but let's see wow
hamza thought this is like a once a year
kind of thing
you know i mean just just once a year we
can grab hold of him he's so busy and
hamdulillah
doing his things but yeah um
jake is gonna be proud of you yeah all
the heresies
i'm learning so much with that brother
martial allah
jake is going to be back at the not the
next arena the one after it inshallah
uh shaketh man and yusuf
um are in the next arena
um again muhammad jabez tafan fareed
responds
refried responds i need to get fareed uh
on this one
because him and um
[Music]
sheikh of man have the same kind of
skill set when it comes to the hadith
and such so i need to bring
farid into this one
and and that column there just shows how
demo how delusional woody is
uh beg atheist on bait atheist on reddit
okay maybe inshallah you guys need to do
that so you guys do the job
um i'm going to join clubhouse with
brother e jazz
and uh we'll bait some christians
martial the thing is all christians are
just like
they've been at what's next it's really
hard trying to find something
substantial to learn
because they just come with the same
nonsense oh
yeah i tried to bring shabir yusuf but
he was busy maybe i'll try and get him
to come on the next one inshallah i
don't know
norm was the type of i think they watch
your video they're too scared to come
bro you've got you've gotten all your
stuff to come here
hamza staying at the founders of islam
in spanish tv on the stream honestly the
guys and girls my channel deserve
exposure they're doing wonderful work
okay inshallah
anyone's welcome mate if so if a jew
wants to come into the arena
you're welcome no problem we don't only
challenge christians we challenge
christians jews atheists agnostics
hindus buddhists seeks
whatever you want to just come to the
arena with it man
we don't uh discriminate me
yeah i'm gonna go jump on ark now
uh yeah zakir yeah
stop that top lad so many good brothers
of you know
sorry i didn't even mention hashim so
the next arena
standard three already hashim uh
sheikh of man and yusuf ponders is the
three and me is four and just one brucey
um and and so it's like yeah
i might have to start with more than one
arena more than two arenas
streamer quest
i'm still debating that
if how would you respond to hinduism
hinduism is too deep to understand
i'd say tell me about the monkey army
just tell me about the monkey army tell
me the story
talk to me about the god that lost his
wife and then
asked the monkey god to bring his monkey
army to rescue his wife
after a year
that would remember any hindu comes on
that's the question they're getting
[Laughter]
oh dear
let's get zishan's mouth to jannah maybe
inshallah
like i say uh
don't mock the monkey army you've been
warned
um my advice to you woody
um you've subbed to the gin and tonic
show
don't come to the arena with their
arguments you're just gonna look stupid
all right i'm gonna go now salaam
alaikum
i'm going to leave you with this thought
i love that picture i love that picture
all right
here comes the goat oh sorry sorry here
comes the lion